there is no safe level of alcohol
consumption none zero every single drink
that you take is moving you closer to
death I wish I didn't think about things
as much I wish I didn't care about
things as much I wish I didn't worry I
wish I didn't have as much anxiety guess
what you do and the only way out is
through your intuition is probably right
about a lot of things and it gets
perverted by other people how could guys
increase their attractiveness the age
old question so I think the best piece
of advice
is Chris Williamson thank you so much
for coming on the iced coffee hour this
means so much I'm a huge fan of your
podcast I absolutely love it it's a big
inspiration for me and us here on the
iced coffee hour so thanks for coming on
man thank you for having me why should
anybody listen to you that's a great
question uh I came up with it thank you
well that was my I guess I think a lot
of people probably ask that question I'm
not really too sure I'm a guy that
follows his curiosity uh and I started
talking to people on the internet and
accidentally made it into a job I think
that a lot of people especially guys
toward the end of their 20s realize that
they're a little bit confused about what
they're supposed to want in life and
about what they're supposed to like and
maybe they have or haven't achieved
success in a way that they think is
supposed to fulfill them and they don't
feel that fulfilled and that was me and
then I decided if I'm going to do this
podcast then maybe I'll find out kind of
how the world works and understand
myself and understand other people and
then 730 episodes later I've managed to
do that but I have no Authority like you
largely shouldn't listen to me but the
people that I speak to you probably
should listen I made a career of being
the most stupid in the room like 73
times in a row why do you think so many
people resonate with you I'm a pretty
normal guy in many regards and
have very open about my own flaws and
and shortcomings and uncertainty and
stuff like a lot of impostor syndrome or
lack of confidence or whatever it might
be uh despite having done 15 years
running the biggest events company in
the UK and love Island and take me out
and all of these reality TV shows and
stuff maybe there's something reassuring
about seeing someone go on the same
personal growth Journey that you are Ali
abdal has this great idea where he says
that you don't want to teach someone
who's 10 steps behind you because you
can't remember the problems that they're
dealing with you want to teach somebody
who's sort of two or three steps behind
you I've done this show for seven years
now so I've just left this huge trail of
breadcrumbs so I'm now I'm like fighting
with meditation so guess what like what
what listening to a meditation guy every
other week for like four months and now
I'm going to learn about dating or now
I'm going to learn about evolutionary
psychology and now I'm going to learn
about AI or whatever and everyone's come
along for the ride so I guess uh yeah
everyone's following in my wake do you
think now it's harder for you to relate
to the people who are just starting out
in some ways in some ways yes but I
think the principles still remain the
same sure like you need to be consistent
you need to make it as easy as possible
to do the things that you need to do
which usually means finding something
that's enjoyable you need to follow your
instincts as opposed to trying to
compromise them for what other people
say that you should do and that works at
episode 1,000 and episode one but
through this process of personal growth
I see you now obviously handsome man you
got everything going for you you got a
successful business you got massive
muscles by the way do you take creatine
or no yeah of course okay GRS five every
day see you said of course we had hormos
on here he said no he doesn't take
creatine yeah that's true but he's also
like a super Androgen receptor guy right
like that's what he claims homeboy
homeboy got like 125 testosterone levels
and looks like an animal we want to know
because you said that in the beginning
you started out as like a somewhat
insecure person you had the only child
syndrome you didn't have friends and you
got bullied and stuff like that the
whole process of obviously getting to
this point right now where everyone sees
you and you're like the looks maxing guy
he's got all the muscles and power
whipping on the compliments I'm I'm just
curious man fine honestly I really I
should suck the podcast off and being an
only fans that's it would do well yeah
get through school being pretty
unpopular uh just a lot of people out
there especially only kids will not have
the amount of socialization that they
need so they don't learn the Finesse of
how to play the social game particularly
well and ultimately what you're trying
to do is just relate to other kids
around you during school but you don't
know how to do that and you end up
feeling disjointed in one way or another
and that was me throughout most of
school and I kind of got to University
at Newcastle and finally got the
opportunity you remember every summer
you'd come back from being away and
think I'm going to reinvent myself this
year I'm going to be the cool kid or I'm
going to be the sporty one or I'm going
to be the smart one or whatever but this
is like the ultimate version right
because there's no one that's going with
you there was no not a single person
that I knew from the first 18 years of
my life that was going to Newcastle
which was the place that I went to
University which gave me the ultimate
opportunity to kind of reinvent myself
and um I started doing Club promo
straight away flying on the street so I
sat down at a seminar my first ever
lecture and said I've spent all of my
maintenance Alan which was like your
spendy loan during Fresh's week getting
drunk sat next to a guy and he said oh
well I'm going to go and do Club F
flying flying for nightclubs you should
come with me and 15 years later that guy
was still my business partner if this is
a problem that most people go through
specifically young men why do you think
you suffered more yeah I don't know I
maybe how painful something is probably
is a motivator right that you can run
towards something you want or run away
from something that you fear and I think
that I'd spent sufficient time getting
toward the end of my 20s and
realizing I don't really understand
myself I haven't really fully connected
with the work that I'm doing or the
people that are around me and this felt
like a legacy this was a trend
throughout my life right that I'd had it
as a kid and then I'd thought well I'll
fix it by being successful and popular
publicly and then go on reality TV and
get a bluetick and and run this huge
events company and put a million people
into club nights and that didn't fix it
so I'm like well like you know I've
looked outside a lot and I've tried to
fix it that way I guess I might probably
be a good idea to try and look inside
now why do you think you had this like
desire to understand yourself a lot of
people that I've met and I don't want to
point out any names seem to be fine
seemingly mindlessly kind of just going
through the motion why do you think you
had all of these bigger deeper questions
that you needed to satisfy because the
pain of not realizing them was way worse
there's this idea from senica it's
really brilliant and he explains about a
man who you would ask him as he steps
out of the door on a morning what he's
going to do with his day and he says I
don't know I'll I'll see some people
I'll do some things and he describes him
by saying they do not what they intended
but what they happened to come
across and that to me sounds like hell
that sounds like life happening to me as
opposed to me happening to life so it's
a difference of being a CK that gets
sort of thrown into the sea and Bobs
around for a year and then you take the
cork back out and you speak to the Cork
and you say what did you do and you say
well I traveled to some places and I did
some things that's being on a journey
but it's not the same as being in a ship
right being in a ship ship carves its
path and it actually goes from place to
place under its own agency so to me I
wanted to be able to be intentional with
the things that I do in my life and I
wanted to have life stop just happening
to me I wanted to happen to life so this
journey is you went to college you
started becoming a club promoter correct
can we can we talk about how that ended
up happening not everyone just goes to
college and becomes a club promoter did
you to like a seminar to do it's a
professional training course yeah how
but how do you pick that was that was
one of those things where you heard
about it and you show up
night sat next to a guy I said I was I
was completely broke and he said well if
you want to come and uh give out flyers
you know you live walk past nightclubs
hey man free shots tonight come on in so
I started doing that and then within the
space of six months was a event manager
within the space of a year got our first
franchise it was a good time with a
particular franchise we picked up that
at 19 so I started doing that then at
2122 we started our first weekly and
then we just built a portfolio of event
out from there is there a catch cuz I
walk down the Vegas Strip all the time
and I see these guys they're coming up
to me there's not a catch there's not a
coming to the club man coming to the
club like why why me it's I hate to say
it but if I'm you must look like an easy
target yeah but I think if they that guy
look like a degenerate let's bring him
in here they want me to go to the club
it probably is not a club worth going to
but they're not discriminating you know
sales a sale clicks a click uh so for
them they just they just want to get
anybody in that they can so they want to
make it busy of course okay of course
yeah so here's something that's
interesting about nightlife right we're
here in Vegas like home of nightlife
right events are one of the very few
businesses where the other consumers of
the product are the primary offering of
the product itself so we've all got
iPhones we don't have iPhones because
Brad Pit's got an iPhone we have iPhones
because of fundamentally intrinsically
what the iPhone can do and there's a bit
of fluff in terms of branding and like
status and [__] like that yeah a little
but mostly it's because what it does
right if I ring Jack after he's been to
a night out and I said dude how was the
night last night he goes bro it was
insane there was so many girls there and
I'm like I asked what the night was like
not who are the other consumers of the
event that you went to and it's this
vicious sort of cycle that occurs within
NTI where the
key feature of your experience of the
event are the other people who are also
consuming the event which gives it this
like very mimetic upward trajectory
which means that you can start something
in within 3 weeks it's the hottest thing
in town and thousands of people want to
go and then also I've seen
200,000 a year businesses just go
completely because they've been on the
receiving end of the next new thing
which is then coming taking all of their
customers away so I'm someone who goes
Comfort over style any day it's true
I've seen what you wear in public and
I'd be embarrassed all right Graham well
at least with our sponsor vessie I can
be comfortable and look good at the same
time so on a serious note I've been
wearing vesties since 2020 when they
sent us a pair and no joke I've been
wearing them almost every day since then
I still have the same pair of shoes they
sent me back then I still wear them they
still hold up and what I like most about
them and especially their Soho sneaker
is that it looks like a really expensive
shoe like I have some shoes that are
worth several hundred and this one in my
opinion looks better it's more
comfortable and it's waterproof so I got
some shoes from vessie back in 2020 I
still wear those shoes to this day these
shoes though on the other hand they sent
me these like a couple of months ago go
and they are my favorite slip-ons I've
ever had in my entire life I wear them
every single day they still look as good
as new obviously the bottom it's going
to be a little bit dirty because I I
walk a lot in them but it's amazing how
waterproof they are and also amazing how
comfortable they are trust me I
guarantee you'll love them in terms of
style they also have the everyday
Classics Boardwalk slip-ons everyday
moves weekend Chelsea Sunday slippers
and a bunch more each shoe also comes
with a 365-day dry sock guarantee and if
you buy a pair that doesn't quite fit
not a problem vessie will exchange them
for free so feel free to check them out
down below in the description when you
go to
vessie check him out and try a pair for
yourself by the way guys vessie didn't
ask us to do this but we're so confident
that you'll absolutely love them that if
you buy a pair of vessies and then you
post a story on your Instagram and tag
the iced coffee hour which is linked
down below we'll repost that story the
first five people be sure to check him
out thanks so much so let's talk about
where exactly you were in your life
during that time were you in the gym
yeah yeah so I I trained as soon as I
got to University I wanted to stop
feeling I was bullied throughout school
and I was like 67 kilos so I was like
just tiny and I wanted to feel more self
assured and I wanted to feel like a man
as well I think a lot of guys like deep
down when they start going to the gym at
age 18 it's them wanting to kind of
speed up that maturation from being a
boy to being a man because even though
legally you might be a man and you know
functionally you might be a man like
physically a lot of the time unless
you're a unless you're Alex and you're
like a super responder to testosterone
or whatever it's still going to take you
time so you're trying to speed that up
so I was doing that how did you reinvent
yourself in that one summer between high
school and college what was that process
like did you wake up one morning and
just say to yourself you know what I'm
going to change this and what did you do
what were the steps involved so it took
two years of high school of me I got my
first girlfriend and started to hang
around with people that were a little
bit more like me and so I was I guess a
slow introduction to that but there
wasn't the heavens didn't open and I
didn't go now you will be super chat
club promoter extraordinaire that didn't
happen um it was just one iteration at a
time but even within that like I found
strange weird quirks of Club promo like
I'd not go out to the events that
everyone wanted to go to to party and
I'd stay in and read bodybuilding.com
forums which was like the equivalent of
like an big back in the day huge the M
forum
[__] but um yeah there wasn't nothing
the skies didn't open that wasn't there
wasn't like some moment that happened it
was very very slowly I just tried to
craft myself into the sort of person
that other people would want to be
around but that was also a problem that
wasn't me crafting myself into me that
was me trying to model what I saw other
people wanting to be around and then
becoming that guy which is also a
problem right just more internal
conflict but less external conflict so
is it like a bit of a m fake until you
make it sort of fake it just continue to
fake it right and then realize that
you've just built up this huge Persona
about who you are this party boy this
big name on campus well Chris is always
there he's the guy that will run the and
again it doesn't matter whether you are
running club nights whether you are the
sort of person that is around a group of
friends that you don't really resonate
with a lot of the time when you're with
them you would sooner
be you would sooner be
accepted for a falsehood than be alone
for the truth in many ways which causes
people to Verge
toward compromising themselves and
playing a persona but it's not very
fulfilling so you went through this
transformation what is your answer to
the people that are still stuck in Phase
One of wanting to change but not
actually changing what's your answer to
the question of the age-old question I
should say of like why do some people
know that they should change and they
know how to change but they still don't
if they're watching this then they know
that they should change like if you've
got two hours to watch us three waffle
on about like psychology and life and
and things like that you already know
right I I think it fundamentally comes
down to people wanting to take action
there are people out there who are just
blissfully able to curse through life
and it's fantastic there was this the
first time I ever went to go and see
Peterson talk live he um he got asked
this question and this person said the
depth of my Consciousness causes me to
suffer is it a blessing or a curse to
feel everything so very deeply I was
like [__] give that person a podcast
whoever asked that a phenomenal question
right which is's kind of tangential to
what we're talking about here as well
right like I know this thing but I don't
do this thing is the pain of insight
worth the the the the discomfort of
being able to so on so forth and uh
Peterson thought for a moment and he
said the only way out is through you
take more of the thing that poisons you
until you turn it into a tonic that
girdles the world around you I was like
that's [__] awesome you would say
that God like apocalyptic piece of Life
advice it's brilliant right and it
really spoke to me because there will be
a lot of people listening who think in
some ways I wish that I saw the world in
less of a complex way I wish that it was
more like easy to me whatever that even
means it should just be kind of I wish I
didn't think about things as much I wish
I didn't care about things as much I
wish I didn't worry I wish I didn't have
as much
anxiety but guess what like you do
so how are you going to play the cards
that you've been dealt and that's a huge
Advantage tons and tons and tons of ways
except for a couple and the pains are
very obvious and all of the rewards are
very hidden so you need to go through
the only way out is to find them let's
take it back to when you were doing the
club promoting could you talk maybe
about your income over that period and
how it changed with the different levels
that you were at and maybe your status
as well yeah do you get paid like per
person you bring in how does that work
so very quickly uh originally you would
have done it based on commission so
homeboy on the street that's trying to
finagle you to go into his nightclub
he'll get
paid $2 $5 $10 per person or whatever
for the people that go in so first it's
on commission then you'll get put on a
retainer with commission for us God I
think I I think my original manager's
fee retainer was £25 a week and I was
working like a dog like going around
Halls knocking on doors but it it was
status as well well and there was this
promise of uh promotion too and also
you're 18 and you've got no money so 25
bucks or 25 is going to go like not
nowhere so originally you would be on
commission then you'll end up getting a
retainer you'll also tend to be paid for
shifts that are worked so if you work on
the till or if you work on the front
door or if you work in VIP or you do
whatever and for most of that stuff
you're checking tickets you're checking
wristbands you're shmoozing people
you're doing whatever there are tasks
that need to be done so you'll just get
paid a flat fee for that I'm pretty sure
it was £5 an hour when we first started
doing it so not a fantastic wage but
again you're 18 and you're getting paid
to drink like like it's a dream in some
ways um then we span that up into the
franchise our first ever franchise was
called Carnage which was a t-shirt bar
roll anyone who is over the age of 32
from the UK will know this it was an
institution it was a license to print
money when we started doing it so you
bought a t-shirt wore the t-shirt and
that was your ticket and that got you
into all of these venues and those tasks
on the back pulled a pig swapped shoes
with someone uh like you know a bunch of
different things that you needed to do
and you had to take off all of the
different venues that you went to and
this is 2007 to
2012 Larry British drinking culture so
you're writing the first half of the
alphabet down the left half of your arm
and the second half down the right and
you have to kiss someone that's got the
first name of each letter so everyone's
sprinting around looking for a Zara at
like 2:30 in the morning trying to find
someone with a name that begins with zed
and um that was what we did and we did
that for a long time and that kind of
established us that was a franchise
model and we were taking 15% of that so
I think I was maybe making three grand a
term so nine grand a year from doing
that uh but that was doubling my
maintenance loan from University so I
basically had double maintenance loan
which was phenomenal and uh that that
paid my way through through uni how
would you balance your life at that
point because I'd imagine the club
promoting would be really late college
would take a lot of your time is is
there no time at all is it dude is it
easy it was a business degree it was a
business degree anybody that tries that
tries to tell me that a business degree
an undergraduate business degree is hard
shouldn't be at University like what are
you doing it's the I within the first
four weeks of being at University I
completely fell out of love with
Academia I was like I'm seeing in the
real world what HR or marketing or
accounting or B2B or b2c or like any of
this stuff I'm seeing what it is and
then I'm being something and what I'm
being taught Bears no resemblance to
what I'm seeing in the what are they
teaching you in regards to that like
Henry for's models of Scientific
Management lean Kaizen like all of the
like just dog [__] like I'm not dude I'm
not going to go and [__] design a
Nissan factory right like and if I am am
I going to remember what I learned at
undergraduate there was nothing about
the key skills that I was learning which
were networking sales copywriting there
was none of that stuff which I'm going
to guess that you guys would agree like
real high Leverage High Lage things I
don't care about Japanese workplace
culture for lean management like and I'm
never going to use it so I just was like
all right well I guess it became very
transactional I did a masters I did five
years at Uni I did a masters in
international marketing and again I
submitted I submitted my Master's
dissertation completed in 36
hours by doing three grams of what was
supposed to be cocaine but my dealer was
having a bad week and a case of Red Bull
and I still managed to pass that
degree it was a joke but I got the piece
of paper ticked it off and it was done
so why do you think college is just it
seems to be more of a hassle and a
problem than what it's worth where do
you think that change occurred it seems
as though maybe 50 years ago 40 years
ago that college actually really taught
you something do you think that maybe
technology is speeding up faster than
people could teach it but before we go
into that as Chris will tell you running
a business could be tough and it's even
harder when you're using multiple
softwares trying to compile everything
together it's often a waste of time and
energy but thankfully your sponsor
netsuite is there to help and all you
have to do is remember these three
numbers 37,000 25 and 1 37,000 because
that's how many companies have switched
to netsuite and stopped doing things
like typing in manual data entry and
searching through scattered information
25 because netw has spent 25 years
helping businesses drive down their
costs and one because netsuite is an
all-in-one solution that allows you to
manage your kpis or key performance
indicators with one efficient system net
we can help reduce the mistakes from
manual data entry and trust me if you've
ever done manual data entry there will
always be mistakes and they'll prevent
the busy work from scaling with your
business so have a full picture of your
business and help make better decisions
faster right now you can download
netsuite's popular kpi checklist for
free at nets.com once again guys it's
nets.com to get their popular kpis
checklist for free it's absolutely free
just try it out okay guys you don't have
to spend a single Cent at netsuite.com
iced thank you so much natu and back to
the episode it seems as though maybe 50
years ago 40 years ago the college
actually really taught you something do
you think that maybe technology is
speeding up faster than people could
teach it yeah perhaps
um the world of business is moving and
the world of work is moving way more
quickly than
the slow lumbering institutions that are
trying to play catchup and trying to
teach people how to do it and like the
best way to learn how to Squad is to
squat right and you can watch all of the
video in the world that you want but
ultimately it's just go and do the thing
and you will find out how to do it um
for me at least when I was at University
I wasn't engaged with the lectures the
300 people in the lecture super popular
course right business management at
Newcastle University which is what we
would it's like a red brick University
it's one of like the top six or whatever
in the in the UK I just wasn't learning
anything I didn't care about the
lecturers I didn't respect the lecturers
I didn't think I was learning anything
that was interesting it wasn't engaging
and yeah the world continues to move
more quickly than Academia can catch up
to it so it doesn't surprise me that
people are disenchanted with it that
being said I am way more Pro University
than almost any of my friends I still
think that I gained huge huge huge
amounts of of uh progress from it but it
was almost exclusively from the
lifestyle that I had outside of it it's
like you condense 10 Years of Living
into three years you need to learn what
it's like to have an argument with your
friend at 3:00 a.m. in the morning when
you guys have all traveled to some other
City to go and to go and party or to do
something or you need
to both like the same girl that's on the
hockey team that you're playing with or
whatever like it's important to have
those formative experiences and
University condenses all of that
together so for me that really sort of
sped up my maturation although that
might be partly due to the fact that I
was so uh back like socially backward
coming in that that ended up being my
training ground that was like my Navy
sale hell week that lasted for five
years on how to be a social socialite I
can see that how did you then go from
doing that to being on love Island that
seems so random to be able to oh dude
from being promoter club promoter to
love Island pipeline is well known this
is a common this is a common pipeline
don't forget I didn't I was a commercial
model for like a decade as well right so
model DJ club promoter reality TV star
that's the Four Horsemen of the
Apocalypse okay like that's the big four
that you need um yes I did this show
called take me out which is kind of like
a more fluffy dating show that happens
before the Watershed which is like so
there's no swearing there's no like LW
[__] um I did that when I was
23 I think and I had a huge afro white
guy afro and um that was like fun I just
wanted status I still was chasing so
hard for people to recognize me for
people to respect me because I realized
that if people needed me that was the
same as them liking me it's not but it's
close enough functionally it ends up
kind of being the same thing like if
they need me to get into the nightclub
or if they need me because they think
that I've got a big Twitter following if
they need me because I was on that
reality TV show that's kind of the same
as them liking me or wanting me and
maybe those two crossed but that was me
trying to reverse engineer I wasn't
popular in school let's work out a way
to be popular and a routin is to be a
useful conduit between them and
something that they want even if the
thing that they want is to be associated
with so did you purposely seek out a
show and then apply to be on or did they
come to you and say how do they find you
modeling so they go to modeling agencies
because they need to spend they need to
look for people who are comfortable
being on camera who have got some level
of looks that they think is like going
to suit TV or whatever so take me out
did exactly that and then the same guy
that cast me on take me out three years
later rang and said uh hey man I've got
this new show would you mind coming and
Screen testing for it and I was like oh
yeah cool like I catch up with this guy
that I knew that I respected and I
thought was interesting uh
and go to a hotel in Newcastle sit down
in front of him he's feeding the ansers
behind the camera of what he knows that
the producers and the exx will want to
hear so it's evident that he wanted to
put me on literally before I knew it I
was in an open top jeep driving to a
villa in the middle of mayorca they've
taken my phone off me they I've been on
media lockdown for an entire week with
supervision from a chaperone um and then
yeah I was away for a full month no
contact of friends family no
distractions no books no TV no internet
no nothing and you're like just how bun
of reality TV is real almost all of it
in my experience I can't speak for all
shows and here's the litus test the
reason you know reality TV for the most
part is real is because all of the
people that are on there are way too
stupid to be able to act the things that
you think that they're acting what you
think that Joana 18-year-old hairdresser
from Wigan is going to be right Joanna
thank you for that we're just going to
run it again but can we get a little bit
more emotion out of you this time dude
no like no that the the people that are
on there are there to just enact their
life forward they're not actors they're
not I mean maybe some of them are able
to do like a little bit of turn it up
turn it down do all the rest of it but
they're not they're not contrived enough
to be able to do that just on command
especially if it's a show like love
Island which is every single night I
think it's 4:00 a.m. is the cut off the
next day the full 24 hours is condensed
into 45 minutes of like 100 camera
angles and stuff what so they would be
able to every single day
like create some narrative and play some
role like no way sure there's no so for
me there's something called a villa
producer which will come in and this
will be the same on The Bachelor it'll
be the same on whatever they'll come in
and they'll say we think it would be a
bit more exciting let's say that uh me
and you like Jack right and I I fancy
him and you fancy him and we're
like the producer will come over and go
Chris how do you feel about the fact
that uh Graham's been chatting to Jack
earlier on today you like I got to be
honest like it really p pissed me off I
thought we were friends I really thought
that he liked me you go well why don't
you go and have a chat with him over by
the fire pit and you go all right yeah
cool and over by the fire pit there's a
[__] ton of camera set up and
everyone's like ready to go so they're
there poking CU they can't wait three
weeks for you to pluck up the courage to
say like will you hold my hand they need
it to happen now yeah so they're like
they they catalyze stories but they
don't fabricate stories and the reason
they don't fabricate stories is because
people don't have the skill set to be
able to be like oh and now I love
[__] like Jonathan and now I love
like and now I'm out of love with
everyone it's like you're just there
doing the thing that you do but how do
they get people to be so like
confrontative cuz it seems like if they
were to ask me that question very good
selection process really so they just
pick people that are going to like on a
dime Let's Lose It of course of course
yeah like alcohol too because I noticed
on Netflix they all have those golden
cups and everyone you know there's
always alcohol in that from what seems
to be the moment they wake up until they
go to bed they're drinking all day long
one of the things I really respect it
and I got in trouble I get in a bit of
trouble because I did this big podcast
the first other one that I did that blew
up seven years ago was what it's really
like to live on love Island and this is
when it was still a huge TV program and
I like opened the door behind the fact
that we didn't ever know what time it
was they didn't give us watches and all
the clocks inside of the Villa were the
wrong time and when the sound guys came
in to change your sound packs they
changed their watches and when you got
in a car to go on location they' changed
the time they never wanted you to know
what the time was what yeah I think they
wanted to control our sleep pattern more
than uh it's like an inside of a casino
and there was other there was a ton of
other things right just like little [__]
but it was fun like that it's not
malicious or it's whatever but anyway I
did this thing they wer too happy about
it the alcohol thing is is interesting
because it catalyzes the story which is
exactly what they were looking to get
done but the problem is it causes
everyone's Behavior to kind of like
gravitate toward the same type of stuff
it's always going to be Larry fighting
aggressive kind of sloppy and what I
respected about love Island despite the
fact that I got them in a bit of trouble
was they Limited everyone's alcohol to
two drinks a day which is like a noble
thing to do because they could have
given us more alcohol and had like more
story lines but it would have been this
is coming out the back of our equivalent
of Jersey Shaw was called Jordi Shaw
that was where I was from that was
Newcastle and they didn't want that they
didn't want people to be fighting and
puking and pissing on the floor they
didn't want that that didn't look fun to
them so they decided to make it a more
like romantic love Island right they
wanted to make it a more mature kind of
thing and that was the same throughout
one problem that they didn't foresee is
I don't smoke so this isn't an issue for
me but a lot of people who do smoke
apparently when they get in the sun all
that they want to do is just [__] RI
darts all day and one of the problems
was as with everywhere you need to have
a smoking area you can't have people
smoking all over for health and safety
and fire hazard and all the rest of it
but it meant that like 50% of the scenes
from my season were done in this one
like 2 met x 2 met smoking area because
like half of the guys were going through
a 20 pack a day as they were smoking
these cigarettes uh but you also know if
you are I was 27 when I did it like if
you're 27 full of testosterone and
around a bunch of girls all you want to
do is like drink right like you're there
a party but you're permanently being
limited to two drinks a day like two 330
mil cans of stubby beer which was just
like yeah it was in it agitated a lot of
people in some ways so but it was fun it
was fun and I fewer people have been to
the top of ever than have been in love
Island wow I'm not equating the two okay
but you know there's not many things you
can do that not many done yeah and
that's one of the things I'm like H okay
at what point do you forget that there
are cameras there because I hear a lot
of people say that at first you're
nervous if there's all these cameras but
then after like a day you forget they're
even there and I see some of these shows
and I think why would you do that on
camera but you know what before we go
into that really quick I think
podcasting over the next few years is
only going to get bigger I mean when we
started very few people were doing it a
lot more people are hopping on the
bandwagon but if you want to get started
doing something similar to us you don't
need to spend all the tens of thousands
of dollars of equipment that we have you
could get started today with our sponsor
streamyard streamyard is a live
streaming and content creation software
that allows you to create high quality
content with just the click of a button
all you need is a camera and an internet
connection and you can stream right from
your browser and one of my favorite
things about streamyard is they have a
multistream feature that allows you to
stream onto YouTube Instagram Facebook
LinkedIn and all of these different
platforms at the same time they also
have a whole bunch of analytics tools
that tell you exactly how many people
are watching how long they're watching
for when they're dropping off and all of
these things are very helpful to keep in
mind so if you want to start creating
content just like the iced coffee hour
and you want to get started right now
and for free check out streamyard with
the link Down Below in the description
once again it's completely free we have
been using them now for years we highly
recommend them the link is down below in
the description enjoy let us know what
you think and now let's get back to the
episode at what point do you forget that
there are cameras there because I hear a
lot of people say that at first you're
nervous that there's all these cameras
but then after like a day you forget
they're even there and I see some of
these shows and I think why would you do
that on camera well the whole point of
reality TV is to make things feel
naturalistic right it's to so let's say
that this was we were here and the pools
over there they'll have like one of
these light bulbs will actually be a
camera and there'll be a little CCTV
sort of swivel thing like a security
camera you'd have and there'll be a
couple of big booms but the guy will be
on one of those bazooka thing you know
like you get at sports matches where the
guy like sits in it it's like a [__]
50 cal machine gun there'll be that and
it'll be that'll be my shot and then
there'll be another one here and
there'll be some other stuff and
there'll be one inside of a bush the
whole point is to make it feel
naturalistic and people do forget um and
after a while to be honest you kind of
just get Stockholm syndrome you're like
well this is life now I don't remember
what life was like without this so I
guess I'm just going to crack on was it
weird for you finishing the show and
going back to real life and seeing a
clock and just looking around like no
one's recording me it the first couple
of days was strange yeah I think I was
there I'd had one week of media lockdown
where I'd had that chaperon uh I read
Paulo quo The Alchemist which this is a
niche piece of advice but if you're
about to go on a reality TV show do not
read Paulo quo's The Alchemist before
you go on because you just end up in
this like psychedelic Fugue State and
because it's all about this guy and he's
traveling through the uh fields of Spain
and I was in Spain and he's on his own
and he's going on this journey of
self-discovery so I was just thinking to
myself the entire time that I was there
it's just like me like I'm doing this
like that was me um it was strange
coming out uh thankfully thank Y and I
say this with all honesty I gained 5,000
followers being on that show so it was
nothing right it was like a a fully paid
broadcasted dress rehearsal to what the
rest of the seasons were going to be
like season two was 10 times bigger
season three was 10 times bigger than
that season four was 10 times bigger
than that now it's kind of plateaued out
but it meant that I was very quickly
able to go back to my my life helped the
club business a bit and people came down
to see me you often get bookings of
reality TV stars at nightclubs and we
basically had one every night of the
week for free which was me which is
great but I was very quickly able to go
back to my normal life which I
appreciate because we lost a deal for
the podcast with a
large airline that was going to host uh
our episodes so that people could watch
them and in the final meeting the final
final pitch meeting one of the main
exacts came in and Googled my name and
one of the things that will come up if
you go sufficiently far down or it might
be a suggested thing on Google will be
love Island and he put that in and
immediately said why would I want to put
the podcast of somebody that's been on
love Island on as like a philosophical
psychological insight uh and that killed
the deal so wow like just that one thing
has been like I'm still wiping some of
the reality TV slime off me in some ways
because like at the time when you're 27
it's cool but there's also a degree of
cringe and you can't kind of quite
project where that's going to be what
AFF did alcohol have on you socializing
and did you ever use that as a crutch I
watched your video about you and your
relationship with alcohol yeah so I was
like a like a classic club promoter
drinker so it' be once every other week
hard very hard and then couple of weeks
off get back into a routine and then
send it again that's that was that was
what it like for maybe a decade from 18
to 28 something like that um so I never
had a dependency I never used as a
crutch for anything but I realized that
I was basically resetting my progress
each week so yeah when I was 28 I
decided to do six months sober and now
everyone's doing elective sobriety or
what's called Lo and no um but then it
was especially as a club promoter like
as the guy right the guy that stands on
the front door of all of the nightclubs
to be it would be like me saying I don't
believe in neut tropics and having a a
[__] neut Tropic drink
um that was kind of a I think a shocking
thing like quite a surprising thing to
do uh but I just I fell in love with
what the progress I was able to make
when I had focus in my life honestly for
a lot of the guys out there and maybe
the girls too if you're struggling to
make progress especially in your 20s and
you keep on thinking I keep on making
these promises to myself about starting
a meditation routine or journaling or
improving my mindset or getting better
sleep or going to the gym or doing
whatever it's like you need to go sober
because even if you're drinking once
every 3 weeks it's not just that it's
that day then it's a day after day after
is a wipe out right even if it's a like
a only moderately heavy night day after
is a complete write off but then you've
already killed the streak that you were
on So You Now need to like restart the
engine of your momentum to go okay well
like well yeah I'll do my meditation Sam
Harris I I'll do the waking up I'll do
that like on Monday you're okay so
there's like two or three days and well
you know the gym I'm still feeling a
little bit like I'm a bit hung over I'm
a bit whatever so I alcohol is a big
part of my upbringing and I think anyone
that says a night out can't be improved
with alcohol hasn't had a sufficiently
good night out like I'm still like a
club promoted through and through but
also as a tool for productivity and
self-improvement going sober is like
literally unrivaled like that and
sleeping with your phone outside of your
bedroom are the two highest Ro do I'm
terrible about the phone I sleep with it
under my pillow so that that way I could
hear the vibrations of what of the alarm
in the morning just dude radio alarm
clock Sunrise alarm clock there's like I
like the vibration alarm clock CU
sometimes m still sleep next to me and I
wake up early and I like that little all
right so this will whoop will do a a
vibration on your wrist uh eight sleep
can wake you up by heat like there's a
million solutions that aren't having
your phone in your bedroom dude honestly
if there's one thing that I can do with
our new burgeoning [__] friendship is
get that thing out of your bedroom know
it's it's it's check that and then it's
go through emails and then it's checking
what the stock market is doing now I
don't check slack it's always that stock
market CNBC Reddit then texts back
around sometimes no but then usually I'm
awake at that point then I could like
get up out of bed and then I feel but
here's the thing I feel accomplished
because I'm like I went through all my
emails I've checked the market I see
what's going on uh you know for work
come up with some ideas and CNBC for
video topics so like I'm planned out so
that's how I kind of justify it but I
would be interested to see what would
happen if you could do like a 30-day
sabatical and go okay I'm going to get
up and go for a walk yep first thing
you've got you know Sunrise is pretty
early here it's it's nice and bright
which is phenomenal nice 10 minute 15
minute walk come back then do it like
just see what change you have there but
the thing is I'm open the main reason
the main reason that I don't like it is
because of what it does on the night
before that if you can't sleep you
always know that you can roll over and
YouTube's there or reddit's there or
whatever's there and you
go [__] and then it's 3 in the morning
and you hate yourself and you've ruined
tomorrow before tomorrow's even begun
yeah I have an easy time going to sleep
the one thing that's honestly really
helped me is a dog in the bed it sounds
so weird dude but like Bailey goes to
sleep consistently at the same time
every night and the fact that she's
going to sleep makes me go to sleep it's
It's oddly calming because it's like 11:
11:30 she's asleep and I don't want to
be like up there on my phone ding about
well on top of that there's some pretty
good evidence that suggests the sound of
a fire or the sound of a snoring dog
improves sleep depth for humans really
yep yeah so think ancestrally right yeah
if you are sleeping in any environment
whether it be one that you are familiar
with the one that you're not familiar
with fire will scare off predators and
keep you warm dog will also be early
warning system so those are cues that
you human does not need to be as
Vigilant during your sleep so during
sleep there's these things called micro
Awakenings right and you can judge the
number of micro Awakenings as a a proxy
for vigilance it's like this is one of
the problems with uh Comedians and
people that go on the road or me like
right now me and my team are on the road
we filmed in Vegas yesterday we're going
to LA tomorrow you can have the most
dialed bedtime routine with the blackout
lines and you've got the face mask and
the nose strip and everything else but
you're not in a place that you know well
and that alienation causes you to be
more Vigilant which means that you will
do more micro Awakenings you were
tracking some herd of whatever the [__]
50,000 years ago and you sleep in an
unfamiliar cave you don't know what's
around you don't know if this is around
or another tribe so it's in your
interests to not go into his deep sleep
this is the same thing that happens when
you're away from your normal bed so you
can optimize your sleep environment as
much as possible but you can't really
work around that problem unless you
bring a dog with you and set something
on fire so so I'm curious I listen to
like sleep sounds in addition to the dog
and the sleep sounds are like you know a
nighttime Forest sometimes headon no
just just one of those little speakers
okay so it sounds like a forest and you
hear sometimes like rain and stuff like
that would you say it's better to listen
to a campfire instead maybe um for me
personally silence like really really
good quality uh sleep earplugs which are
only like 20 bucks on Amazon the ones
that I use um that is just a complete
Game Changer like absolute silence
nothing I could never do that because I
so I'm paranoid and I've always been
paranoid that someone's going to break
in at night dude you community doesn't
matter there's a scary man at the front
does not doesn't matter doesn't matter
so I like to be able to hear the alarm
go off in my sleep he's a very high
anxiety person just for the record so we
only the paranoid survive man so it's
yeah but we also have cameras also that
that give me a notification if someone
steps foot on the property within like
20 and you got a dog yeah so but if
someone steps foot then I get the
notification on my phone first and then
if anything opens I get a beeping or an
alarm and I want to be able to hear that
so if I'm like totally tuned out I I
never want to be in a position where
it's like I open my eyes there someone
there one of my old business partners
Dave who was the guy that was one above
us so he lived in a place in Leeds which
is working-class Town similar to
Newcastle he had a brand new Audi Q7
outside and it's what maybe like an
80,000 pound car 100 Grand car USD some
guys managed to break into his house his
bedroom is on the what we would call the
first floor not the ground floor and
then his brother's bedroom was on the
top floor so these guys had spotted the
car seeing that they had it went into
his house had a look around in the
kitchen couldn't see it in there went
upstairs into his bedroom where he was
asleep took the car keys from the
bedside table be beside where he was
sleeping but didn't go oh we've got a
100 Grand Q7 we can leave then went
upstairs to the next floor to open his
brother's bedroom door take the laptop
out of there close the door go down put
the laptop in the car and drive off that
would be well actually that's not your
worst nightmare because you wouldn't
have woken up and no one would have been
there you'd have just woken up and not
had a car or a laptop yeah I don't care
about stuff like that cuz everything is
insured but for me it's more so like
physical safety is always like that's
that's Paramount if they take anything I
don't care I'm sure that we can come up
with a solution that doesn't involve
that guy being into the pillow though
we'll out we we'll work we'll thr it out
I have a question because for my sleep
I've always struggled with sleep my
entire life it takes me like an hour and
a half sometimes two hours sometimes
like four five hours just lying in bed
because my brain is just moving so
quickly to be able to calm myself down
enough to actually fall asleep sometimes
when I notice like you know cuz
obviously I don't want to look at my and
see what time it is and how long I've
been awake cuz then that makes me
anxious that I'm losing sleep so
sometimes after I know some absurd
amount of time has passed four five
hours or whatever I'll just be like you
know what screw it I need to go on my
phone so I go on my phone I open up
Twitter I do something that's
mind-numbing something that like
decreases my level of stress or just
like the deep thoughts that I'm having
about my career my purpose why I exist
how I'm supposed to do sponsor reads all
of these things I'm trying to tune that
out for something that is so superficial
and just like surface level
and that actually I've noticed decreases
my heart rate and dummies my brain you
tried reading fiction instead I've read
fiction before on an evening time I I
used to actually read fiction but I
selected fiction books that are like I
was reading dovi and that's not like you
know that's one of those books where
like or Crime and Punishment where you
just think and you're like oh if I do
kill someone I suffer a lot from that
rather and you get all these like
philosophical things going on in your
brain you need to be more you need to go
for like a midwit approach here and more
basic like the basic [__] approach of
like I don't know like a nice uh the
Midnight Library by Matt hay or
something it's like Chicken Soup for the
Soul I don't know I I also struggle to
get to sleep which is why it's something
that I've paid a good bit of attention
to Best Thing best stuff that I've
realized for the people who are
interested the 321 method so 3 hours
before you go to bed stop eating 2 hours
before you go to bed stop drinking 1
hour before you go to bed no more
digital lights seems like e-readers uh
don't have the same effect on melatonin
production especially the new Kindles
you can turn it very warm uh so they
don't have the same uh issue that you
would get from using a a phone or using
uh Netflix do you say drinking water two
hours before no more water I've never
heard about that yeah well I mean do you
go to get up to the bathroom in the
middle of the night sometimes I I try to
go right before I go to bed and then
just like pray that I don't have to wake
up trying to cut your uh fluids
consumption will help uh and then
there's all the basic stuff about sleep
hygiene going to bed at the same time
but ultimately like
what you guys do
are like high performance problem
solvers that see issues before they
happen like so ultimately there's always
this degree of like paranoia that's
happening and that is a massive
competitive Advantage huge competitive
Advantage as is portrayed by the like
wall of plags uh what are your thoughts
on melatonin or products that are
designed to help you sleep Derek from
more plates more dates and me had a
discussion about this a little while ago
one of his products from gorilla has
melatonin in I said I thought that that
was bad to take consistently he said
that all of the studies from mice are or
rats are completely overblown I use it
still sparingly I do find that if I've
used it consistently for more than a few
days in a row to a week that my sleep
latency time to bed to time to sleep
that starts to increase so I go careful
with that but uh momentus have got a
phenomenal sleep product that's hubman
supplement company they have a thing
called a sleep pack it's like te the
strip off the top and it's got uh
magnesium L3 and8 uh appenine and
um Aline does seem to help but the main
thing is like go to bed at the same time
dark room cool room if you've got if
you've not got a temperature control
mattress like an eight sleep or an Oola
cooler or something like that will make
a huge difference yeah I worry that
sometimes people are getting too reliant
on like when they wake up I need a
coffee to feel energized and then it's
like I need to go to bed I need this to
go to sleep corre and then people are
like trying to find all these fixes and
it kind of reminds me of uh the story I
heard about Michael Jackson who like
throughout his day needs like different
things like one to bring him up and then
one to kind of bring him down and one to
you know hit the side effects of that
but that has side effects he needs
another one and then it becomes this
concoction of just like all these things
just a function in a day have you ever
looked at what uh Hitler was on during
World War II dude anyone wants to go
down a rabbit hole once you finish this
podcast Dr Theodore Morell was Hitler's
physician and this guy was a [__]
quack absolutely insane by the end of
World War II Hitler's on uh injectable
cocaine bull seen
uh like he's basically on amphetamine
and speed the whole time he's got a pre
parkinsonian Tremor and he puts one hand
out to shake and he can see the other
hand behind his back so it looks like he
was early Parkinson's but he had a
always had bad gut issues and just found
this doctor before he was fully Hitler
and this guy helped him and then he
brought him into the inner sanctum but
they hated him he ate like a pig he was
smelly he was very UNC you know for a
doctor you'd think he would have a
clinical manner but he didn't and uh but
Hitler was adamant that he was you know
a complete wizard but yeah there are a
lot of people that become very very
reliant on them Alex has got this great
Insight where he talks about routines
become superstitions and as soon as it
does that it's dangerous you should be
able to perform no matter what the
precursor is to the thing that you're
trying to do you should be able to get
up and do the podcast without a kind of
new tonic right and that can make you
better you should be able to get up and
write for 2 hours without the the coffee
or the elaborate morning routine in the
cold place you should be able to do
those things and then you get extra but
a lot of people turn routines into
superstitions and I can't do this
without or and that's basically a form
of fragility yeah you really really want
to lean away from that like that routine
fragility is something that I've had to
learn the hard way it's amazing to me
that something like cocaine was so
prevalent back in those days and they
just used it as a medication and you
would even see for kids it's like they
would use like put cocaine in the mouth
and make cocaine great again man [__]
telling you what products do you think
we're using today that could be the
cocaine of the future I think that we're
going to see it's still the like front
wave of alcohol hasn't hit most people
as huberman said and I was there is a
massive study from the lanet that I used
to medically justify to myself some of
the additional reasons that I was put I
did a thousand days without alcohol and
if you can do a thousand days whilst
being a club promoter without alcohol it
can't just be like I want to improve my
meditation streak it needs to be a
little bit deeper than that the Lancer
did the largest ever study on alcohol
consumption and they came up with the
result that there is no safe level of
alcohol consumption none zero every
single drink that you take is moving you
closer to death at a more expedited way
now is that a cost benefit analysis that
you take yeah absolutely everybody does
that all the time that cheeseburger that
you just had like is that like is that
going to move you closer to to health
probably not but it was nice so I'm
going to do it um so I think alcohol is
going to be one of them I think an
overreliance on caffeine is also going
to be one of them as well I think that
people are so dependent on caffeine I
did 500 days without caffeine as well uh
separately to the thousand days without
alcohol doing those both at the same
time would have been [__] miserable
um 500 days without caffeine and that
taught me so much about When You observe
other people's language they don't say
that I'm tired they say I need a
coffee so caffeine papers over the
cracks of your poor restorative practice
your lack of sleep and Recovery the fact
that you're not actually looking after
your Fitness and
you never ask yourself the question well
why am I tired at 11:30 in the morning
like I shouldn't be tired at 11:30 in
the morning maybe it's because you
insist on having a massive high sugar
breakfast every single day you get an
Armond quason every single morning when
you go to to work and you spike your
glucose up through the roof and maybe
that doesn't make you feel good so
that's one of the reasons why when we
put neonic together we wanted to like
not rely on caffeine most people just
have that one lever to press right which
then becomes harder lever to keep on
doing because you become less sensitive
to it which means you need a higher dose
in order to get the same effect so that
was one of the reasons that we tried to
move away from that so I think that
people will realize alcohol I mean
alcohol caffeine are the two big ones
will we see more popcorn lung and [__]
coming through from Vapes do you watch a
big Vape about juel seen it get that on
Netflix you guys would love it yeah it's
awesome awesome like just business
behind the scenes tells you about all of
their financials and uh but I think I
mean what else are people taking those
yep that's what people there was this
huge X threat or Twitter forly known
yeah it got like you sent it to me did
you see that got like 20 million views
basically just hating on the cold plunge
okay do you cold plunge yeah yes of
course you do I I saw your morning not
super regularly but we want we want to
get you to react to this okay I would
love to see you absolutely destroy this
I got it up here here's what they said
cold plunging daily is one of the
dumbest things that you could do sure do
it every now and then not the P it's
made out to be cold plunging is the most
stressful thing you could do to yourself
your body doesn't know you're in a nice
La Studio Co it think the Titanic
sinking in nature falling in cold water
meant that we were going to die as a
result it massiv spikes adrenaline and
all your stress hormones right when you
get out of cold plch it feels amazing
just like how surviving a plane crash
would you thought you would die and then
you didn't this is coming at a massive
cost injecting animals with acute doses
of stress hormones mimics aging you're
basically aging yourself faster for a
mood boost regarding being
antiinflammatory inflammation is a Bad
Thing inflammation your body heals
chronic inflammation is an issue if and
if you're chronically inflamed it means
you need to remove something adding a
cold bunch to cor up the symptoms we are
warm blooded creatures for a reason our
body needs to maintain a temperature
90.6 for everything run optimally and
most people today are already cold the
last thing they need is more yes when
you cunch your body will heat up with
brown fat but what that means is that
energy cannot be used for other things
like your hard function reproductive
system Etc whof God bless the man is the
poster boy for cold punch I hate to say
it but it is very evidently not Saed off
Aging for him just blindly hop on this F
this guy's on fire and and then just
just to top it off they had to throw in
this
[Laughter]
photo oh my God those things can cut
diamonds we we'll throw it up on the for
you guys Poor Joe those are he's getting
a solid like half inch on that on that
length right there impr impressive
what's
the background is that a person an MD
have they got any credentials or is this
them just making a critique from
technically they're verified on Twitter
so okay okay so even better even more uh
alpaca arulius followed by Joe Rogan and
oh no it's Al alpaca aelius so he is a
guy who's like pushing back there's a
bunch of these different accounts one
being carnivore aelius uh I don't know
who alpaca aelius is they might that
person might just be a Critic of this
stuff look I I call blune once a week
maybe I think that the advice is to try
and accumulate 9 minutes of cold per
week um there's a few things that you
can't deny the benefits of uh fasting
sauna and cold plunge and all of them
are the same and it is the sense of
accomplishment when you've completed
something
hard like being able to deal with
difficult things is something that
everybody needs as a skill like I it
wouldn't surprise me if that same
account will also lament the fact that
everyone is like a soft [__] nowadays
and no one can deal with discomfort and
everyone's got trauma or everybody's got
some self- diagnosed issue or everybody
is a victim or everybody's externalized
their locus of control okay well one of
the ways to overcome that is to set
yourself something difficult that you
can do and then do it which could be a
workout which could be sauna which could
be fasting you know if you fast for 16
hours by hour 14 or 15 you're pretty
hungry and like you need discipline to
keep yourself going through especially
if you do like a 2 24 hour fast or 20
hour fast like that's huge the sense of
accomplishment that you have around that
what does that trickle into it tells you
can do other hard things outside of my
domain of competence to start critiquing
whether the hormesis effect is like the
dopaminergic sees is offset with the
fact that you've got more stress hormone
and cortisol going through your body I
don't know not my not my place to do it
I follow a few guys huberman being one
of them and
if until the people that I follow say
stop I'll just keep doing it now and
then so you just talked about everybody
being soft in this these younger
generations and I completely agree and I
think that's realistically I would argue
that could be the biggest problem for my
generation I say maybe your guys'
generation as well you said that you
thought it was The Mating crisis for the
younger generation that was the biggest
problem that they were facing yeah can
you maybe differentiate between the two
and like because I feel like it's hard
to argue that being soft isn't the
biggest problem everybody my age you
know gen Z Etc they're just they can't
do anything they can't they can't
suffering is bad suffering equals evil
to them well the two are intrinsically
linked right um what you have is a broad
culture of risk aversion we could just
call it that it's like people just don't
want to do risky things largely people
are getting their driver's licenses
later they're moving out of the house
later they're getting full-time
employment later they're not having uh
as much casual sex they're not having as
much party time they're not going out
and drinking like you know all of these
things would have been moral panics had
they been the other way around but I
think people are just interested Ed
about okay what does this Suite of
traits this Suite of changes mean and I
think it's pretty evident that it's
called extended adolesence it basically
makes adults into children for longer
and people don't end up growing up how
this relates to the mating crisis is
that if you are still living at home
which is the most common living
arrangement for men under the age of 35
if you're still living at home with your
parents it's going to be very difficult
to date if you don't have a reliable job
it's going to be very difficult to make
you an an eligible partner if you don't
have your driver license it doesn't make
you seem like an independent person so
all of these all of these issues are all
interwoven but the mating crisis and
victimhood culture are like two distinct
problems that need two distinct
Solutions but they feed into each other
as well so why do you think it is that
people are so comfortable constantly
being comfortable and they can't ignore
the elephant in the room that they can't
put themselves in a position of
voluntary suffering because you don't
need to there's no reason to put
yourself through suffering we can go
from an air conditioned house to a
heated seat car we can Uber Eats
ourselves a well-cooked meal while we
watch Netflix on the TV that we Amazon
primed to ourselves like so many of the
rough edges of Life have been eroded so
why would I need to do any at what point
do I find something difficult to do
people have built buildings inside of
which there are heavy things that you
pay to have access to so that you can go
in and lift these heavy things up and
then put them down in the same place and
it's called a
gym that we've had to artificially
create discomfort in our own lives
because it's being completely eroded
from our normal existence does that make
sense like life has been made incredibly
comfortable and convenient and it's
fantastic and why shouldn't it be like
is that not what progress and and
technological advancement is supposed to
do to improve mortality improve quality
of life but there's a difference between
what you want and what is good for you
and what people want is often immediate
comfort and what is good for you is some
degree of resilience training and also
like I'm not a even though we're in his
City I'm not like a David gogin Zite
like never find time to watch Netflix
never find time to chill out like that's
not me that's not the way that I'm wired
I think that it's important to have a a
chill out practice as well as it is to
have a training practice so do you think
it's just people are becoming too
complacent that maybe things are too
good maybe they're not bad enough to
change but you know situation just good
enough it's it comes at a massive cost
to do what feels good rather than what
is needed at a given moment right comes
at huge cost why can people not see that
one is in the long run just overall
objectively better for them they're fine
making that sacrifice how do people get
fat one meal at a time like one day at a
time where they eat 200 calories or 500
calories or 1,000 calories more than
they expended over and over and over
again over a very very long period of
time and the same thing goes for this
like you've read Atomic habits you know
what like you know how it is things that
are good for you typically have pain
immediately and pleasure in the long run
the lead measure is discomfort and the
lag measure is progress why would you
not optimize for the other one you never
actually see the lagging progress until
it catches up with you and you've
got 30 pound overweight and you can't
fit into the old set of jeans that you
used to have right everybody is going to
optimize for what's exactly in front of
them which is usually comfort and it's
not going to be discomfort so I think
that is it a byproduct
what I've called like the male sedation
hypothesis which I think works for women
as well uh screens social media and porn
sedating people out of what would have
typically motivated them to go out and
do things yeah I think that that
contributes an awful lot because people
can get titrated doses of community
Through social media entertainment
through screens and sex through porn so
that they're not motivated sufficiently
to go out and do what would have had to
have happened 100 years ago which is
entertain yourself or find friends of
yourself or have sex yourself so you
always speak about casual sex or I
shouldn't say you always but it seems as
I just can't stop talking about talk
about concept
you it seems like you're speaking about
it in a positive light that is something
that's needed in some capacity H because
the way that most people I feel like see
it as like you know what it's me getting
that instant gratification it feels
awesome although it's probably not a
smart thing there are STDs there's a
scare the risk of pregnancy there's also
just you know putting knowing that my
eventual soulmate is going to know that
I've been in bed with a hundred people
you know what I mean like there are
certain sacrifices that you make with
casual sex but you always speak about it
like casual sex is an all-time low
casual sex isn't an all-time low that
the solution to that isn't have more
casual sex it's low so we got to Big it
high yeah yeah yeah [__] casual sex
great again um so no I'm not I'm
bringing up and I do bring this up quite
a bit that um 50% of men say that
they're not looking for short-term or
long-term relationships right like
between the ages of 18 and 30 we have
all been through a good chunk of that
period and you know what reality
Distortion field the male sex drive is
like during that period I think it's an
interesting comment on oh my God guys
aren't looking for long-term or casual
relationships During the period in which
your sex tribe is maybe at its highest
wow like isn't that an interesting
cultural comment the solution isn't like
just you know turn it into a play by
Mansion freefor all and let people just
[__] on the streets like that's not
that's not what I'm proposing but I do
think that if you were to look at the
problem of victimhood and the problem of
the mating crisis I.E people not getting
together and not being bothered about
doing it maybe victimhood is Upstream
from The Mating crisis but I think the
mating crisis is going to K kill people
more quickly Dr Robert waldinger the guy
in charge of the longest ever
longitudinal study on what makes people
happy the single biggest predictor of
what keeps you living the longest are
the number of relationship sh that
you've got more than stopping smoking
more than going to the gym more than
changing your diet the single biggest
predictor is how many close friends
you've gone doesn't that mean instead of
focusing on let's say optimizing going
to the gym or not drinking or no
caffeine we should optimize instead on
friendships and relationships absolutely
absolutely I'm totally on board with
that one of the problems that you have
is you need another person to do that
like you're not you can go to the gym on
your own and you can do the ice bath on
your own and you can do the sleep on
your own but you need to find other
people but I would wouldn't disagree
maybe one of the things that was lurking
below the surface what was it uh
nicotine uh caffeine alcohol loneliness
yeah you know maybe that would be
something else that would get thrown in
as well almost certainly where do you
see the future of that because it seems
as though we're not going in a direction
where loneliness is getting any better
it only seems worse and it seems as
though different apps are really
designed to keep you on the app as long
as possible and they're only getting
better like all the algorithms that I've
noticed for shorts and T to are only
getting more potent and so it seems as
though at this at the current rate that
we're going they're only going to
continue to get better and better better
to the point where you're going to go on
Tik Tok and it's going to be so
perfectly curated that you can't
possibly get off of it because the
Cliffhanger after every single one is
going to be so great I don't disagree
it's it's scary man if you think that
the algorithms are compelling now at
least they're restricted by most of the
content having to be made by a real
person somewhere when you've got AI
feeding the front end and algorithms
pushing out on the back end you
basically have an unlimited amount of
ultim like infinitely split testable
lyic hijacking content that will just
continue to race to the bottom of the
brain stem so yeah I don't disagree I
think it's I think it's a massive
concern huge huge concern how much time
do you
spend researching and
remembering quotes and studies it's
amazing your ability just to be like I I
got a quote on I just want to say like
my reals feed my YouTube shorts feed
back when I had Tik Tok that feed was
just inundated every swipe it would show
you in some like hyper
granulizer poses somewhere that we just
recorded with hosi yesterday so that
one's going to go out soon and we made a
joke at dinner last night like the
Vietnamese repurposes are going to be
like winding up there oh they're going
to be so getting ready for it yeah um I
don't know I
think remembering Concepts and
remembering philosophies is hard and one
of the easy ways to do it is to have
mantras or little way markers in the
ground and that's one of the reasons
that maxims and aphorisms are so useful
because it's not just this sentence
right it's not just you don't become
Confident by shouting affirmations in
the mirror but by having a stack of
undeniable proof that you are who you
say you are out work yourself doubt
that's hor mosi's conception for
confidence right that you need to do the
thing that's what you remember but what
it means is this whole concept that sits
outside of it which is I should focus on
doing things and earning my stripes as
opposed to just like shouting at myself
about how brilliant I am when I wake up
in the morning when I'm naked like
that's not the rote to do it I was
really embarrassed about my memory when
I first started doing personal growth
like eight or nine years ago because I
was watching a Sam Harris or a Rogan or
a Shapiro or a Peterson or whatever and
their recall ability just seemed to be
unbelievable I remember reading books
and thinking why can't I recall any of
this stuff but over time just crushing
volumes like tons and tons and tons of
exposure ends up with the good stuff
rising to the surface and you can't not
think about it Tim Ferris has this idea
called the good [__] sticks and
basically it completely relinquishes any
need that you feel of having to remember
anything all you remember are the things
that you care about like what was the
thing that you had to send a screen
recording to your friend about like
that's the thing that's the thing that
you can't stop thinking about so just
remember that thing and forget all the
rest of the stuff if you're a doctor
training for medical school this doesn't
work like you need to know all of this
you can't just be like I'm only
interested in the tongue and like the
rest of the body gets forgotten about
but for personal growth just allowing
that stuff to rise to the surface but I
don't spend I don't have a ebbing house
forgetting curve anky flash card space
repetition thing for anything that I do
I spend a little bit of time reading a
lot of time listening a good bit of time
talking and then I write once a week so
I have this little notebook that I write
down some of the most impactful quotes
that I've ever heard and one of them I
heard from you and I think I researched
and found the like where it came from
and it was like a
Stanford uh Stanford college professor
or something like that and I'm going to
totally butcher this but I want to hear
you say it okay it's the have like firm
conv convictions loosely held rather
than loose convictions firmly held or
something like that what is that quote
strong beliefs loosely held not loose
beliefs strongly held yeah I think
that's one of the most beautiful things
and I think every single person right
now listening to this should 100%
practice that I think that is one of the
biggest faults currently at least that's
facing Society yeah well a lot of people
will die on a hill for an idea that they
don't understand MH but how do they know
they don't understand it how self aware
they don't but how but I feel like
there's got to be like a like a point
where you could say I believe in this
but I'm self aware enough to know that I
don't know enough about it how how do
people just get this
undeniable way more it's way more
complex to be able to work out that you
to not just parrot something and then
say Oh I actually don't fully understand
this I should maybe fact check this
thing think about what what we're doing
when we absorb ideology or when we
absorb uh a worldview wholesale right
what we're trying to do is signal our
loyalty to the tribe trying to say so an
ideological belief is as much a show of
fty to your own side and a threat
display to the other as it is anything
else and you can tell this I call it
mono thinking
so you can tell how shallow of a thinker
somebody is by first off how predictable
all of their perspectives are if you
only know one thing that they believe
and secondly how many different
incidents they explain with the same
phenomenon so if I know your perspective
on gun control and from that I can
accurately predict your perspective on
abortion and immigration and the Second
Amendment and the First Amendment and
everything out global politics you're
not a serious thinker because all you've
done is put this onesie on that is oh
that's that's exactly my worldview yeah
they'll correlate together people will
tend to lean left or lean right and a
good amount of that's genetically
predisposed and the other thing is if
everything is because of climate change
or everything is because of capitalism
or everything is because of Donald Trump
you're also not a serious thinker
because the demand for answers outstrips
your supply for them so you just
retrofit the one answer that you have
for one thing across absolutely
everything else but for someone to ask
themselves the question okay so why do I
believe that like why do I think that
thing you don't need to do that you've
already done the show of falty you've
got acceptance from your own side and
this is why it's so rare to find people
that sort of move back and forth left to
right most people pay an unbelievably
high price by doing that because if
you're all the way to the right at least
you guarantee agreement from one side or
all the way to the left you guarantee
agreement from one side if you're in the
middle you guarantee disagreement from
almost all of both but ultimately that's
it's it's a much harder path so of the
quotes I'm so sorry I'm so so sorry keep
coming when I ask for the one that made
for you the number one biggest impact
I'm so sorry had to ask it which quote
made the biggest impact on you
from back in the day there's a book by
Robert Wright called why Buddhism is
true and kenp rimpoche
says ultimately happiness comes
down to the decision of choosing to
become aware of our mental afflictions
or choosing to be ruled by
them and that to me explained why I was
so compelled to work out why I am the
way I am that if happiness is choosing
to become aware of your mental
afflictions or choosing to be ruled by
them I like the only way out is through
that all day long right like I'll take
more of the thing that poisons me until
I turn it into a tonic that girdles the
world around me and that's like the the
common thread in a lot of the different
quotes and and and insights that I have
which is your intuition is probably
right about a lot of things and it gets
perverted by other people this is great
idea called the abalene Paradox so the
abalene Paradox explains how people in a
group can have their truth perverted
even though on their own they believe
something accurately so for instance
let's say that you're getting married
and you think that I want to be invited
to the wedding despite not wanting me
there so you invite me I accept your
invitation to the wedding despite not
wanting to go because I think that you
want me to attend neither of us wanted
either of us to be at the wedding
together but both of us end up at the
same wedding together because we both
thought that that was something that we
wanted to do same thing goes for North
Korea right like everybody supports the
regime and yet if you were to ask them
on their own individually completely
isolated they all probably have a lot of
criticisms but they're all too scared
that somebody else who they don't know
also has criticisms who's going to call
them out about it and this is how
people's intuitions
become swayed to one side or another but
dude like the the Mantra thing and like
the the quotes that I love change all
the time like one of homos like this is
what hard feels like like I think about
that all the time this is is what hard
feels
like did you think the thing that you
wanted to try and Achieve was going to
be easy no okay so what's the entry
price of trying to achieve this thing
well it's hard okay this is what hard
feels like this isn't a bug in the
system this is a [__] feature like
you are here to be challenged by things
this is what hard feels like a couple of
Petersons where he talks about uh be be
precise in your speech he says as he
misspeaks it be precise in your speech
is one of the most important things that
I've tried to do that and pay attention
to I don't know whether they made it
into the books but the original 12 rules
for life was built out of 40 rules that
he wrote in a quar post and it was like
120 I think it's only 44 we're going to
fact check this send it um but anyway I
I had 40 I had 40 on my wall and
uh the two that always stood out to me
were be precise in your speech and pay
attention because they seem to be the
highest Roi uh things that I have relied
on alander Boton had one that that
really really spoke to me sort of
earlier on in my journey loneliness is a
kind of tax you have to pay to atone for
a certain complexity of mind that
basically the more deep of a thinker you
are the fewer people will be like you
dot dot dot and that's fine these things
are they kind of like they make it in my
mind they kind of feel like little
little holes in in a membrane and there
things that you can remember and then if
you decide to open that up and go down
whatever shoot whatever cave that is in
there there's this entire idea that sits
below it but it's reassuring to me
especially as someone who had and still
has a lot of uncertainty am I doing it
right can I be doing it right can I be
doing this better is this the the best
way that I could do it um those things
are little way markers in the ground
that help to sort of remind me that
things are going well how often do you
trust your intuition is that something
you always follow
or no way less than I would like which
is why how many was it 120 40 go God
dang it I thought I was I read that book
three times go [__] yourself you went um
no I it's something that I try to spend
a lot of time like working on I'm
actively trying to work on like bringing
my intuition more yeah yeah because like
the line between is this my Intuition or
is this just an unthoughtful emotional
reaction is a really delicate one
especially for the people that are
listening to this podcast they probably
respect their cognitive horsepower right
they like the fact that they're cerebral
they like the fact that they think about
ideas and that they you know they get to
listen to these interesting people have
come oh what do I actually think about
alcohol oh yeah that's cool I've never
really thought about the thing like that
like that's something that we're all
proud of but we
become trapped we become obsessed with
that to the point where everything is so
left brain if you've read the master in
his Emissary by Ian mcgilchrist [__]
phenomenal book in
ancient confusion times there's this
piece of advice for an aspiring
Confucian gentleman they say the
aspiring confusion gentleman his mat
should always be straight he must know
the exact number of steps that it is
from the edge of the room to the mat and
his bow must always be done at the
perfect angle all of this rigor and
restraint however is aimed at
cultivating a crafted but nonetheless
spontaneous form of naturalism and what
he's trying to do is basically work
incredibly deliberately for a period of
time until that deliberateness can
completely get out of the way and he can
just embody this stuff but the
deliberate like learning the rules of
the game before you break the rules of
the game if you break the rules of the
game before you know the rules of the
game that's just not playing right like
you can't be a Sant like Creator if you
don't know any of the principles of a
thing that you're doing you have to go
through the deliberate F thing first in
Daniel caraman language it would be like
type one and type two thinking right you
have one that's very deliberate and you
have one that's reactive and the goal is
to make the reactive thing be the thing
that was very conscious by working
incredibly hard on being deliberate in
the first
place got it I want to talk about the
difference between being alone and
feeling
lonely do you ever feel lonely having
such such deep thought being so cerebral
in the way that you approach life and
being that that sailboat that crafts
your own course and seeing so many other
people all around you doing the exact
opposite and being a cork sometimes it
used to be worse now that you have the
podcast I'm sure you talk to a lot more
it's better you know it's like multiple
hours per week where I get to speak to
people that think like the way that I do
and then I've built a team out of people
I'm starting to build a team out of
people who think the way that I do too
and also it attracts in like all of the
people that listen to the the show are
people that I would happily go for like
a coffee with they're all interesting
people so by being whatever the little
Hub in the middle and all of these
spokes coming
off you attract the community of people
like the person that you want to be like
so it was a lot worse like I've got in
my journal on my phone I've got like a
multiple entries throughout my 20s just
saying like I think I'm lonely that was
it that was all I put because I didn't
really understand but I wasn't
resonating with with people and that was
almost exclusively my fault because I
wasn't being my true self right like
standing on the front door of a
nightclub isn't exactly the right time
to work out whether the firmy Paradox
about why we haven't seen aliens but
there's a ton of habitable planets is
like why is that not happening it's like
they want to just get the wristband off
you and go in the nightclub and start
kissing someone you know what I mean and
also I wasn't exactly putting that
version of myself out there
so yes it is uh not So Much Anymore how
do you apply all these quotes in your
own life and how do you test what works
and what doesn't cuz some of these
quotes sound amazing but maybe for some
people they just it doesn't hit with
them it's not for them right like it you
know the one from Alanda Boton about
loneliness is a kind of tax you have to
pay for a tone for a certain complexity
of mind if someone isn't particularly
lonely they're going to go don't know
what you're talking about well that's
not for you right but it describes a
very particular type of human experience
but how much of that do you think is
similar to like a horoscope where you
tell a big group of people this and they
find ways to relate that to their own
life oh yeah you know what I'm a really
deep thinker that that explains it for
me and they just find whatever it is you
you tell them they're like oh yeah that
that applies to me I don't disagree I
think that there's many ways in which
people can reverse engineer themselves
to be in the center of almost all
stories uh there's this idea I came up
with a couple of weeks ago called The
Narcissist bed post so when you're
having a conversation with somebody
listen to how many times they use the
word me mine or my and that is directly
correlated with how completely obsessed
they are with themselves because they
can't imagine any story that doesn't
have them in the middle of it and I
think for the most
part people will try and find a way to
make sense of what is in front of them
and it's hard to be a critical thinker
like it's not hard it's hard to not just
like drink the Kool-Aid so to speak oh
yeah like Alex hosi like this is what
hard feels like like that's that's good
but for the people that again it's the
good [__] sticks right like if it
resonates with you you go oh holy [__]
like that really explains quite a lot of
my experience then they go that's for
you and if it doesn't then just like let
it slide now what is it about Alex horoi
that people really seem to resonate with
it is consistently anytime we go out
especially at the gym people come up and
say that podcast with Alex rosi I love
that I've been addicted to Alex rosi
since then we don't we have never had a
guest that has that level of conviction
like Alex rosi has why do you think that
is what what is it that Alex fosi is
talking about that resonates with so
many people that just cck it's a degree
of self-belief I think and hope that you
can do hard things and he's very honest
I think he's very very honest about the
fact that he is fallible and flawed and
it's empowering it's like it's in in the
actual definition of the word it's like
it's an inspiring message to hear that
someone who is trying to do very very
difficult things can go about them and
like here's a road map of how they did
it and it synthesized down into a way
that's easy to remember like Al is
basically an aphorism machine right but
the reason that he's an aphorism machine
is he's obsessed with words he's a
writer first people think that he's like
a businessman or he's a podcaster or
he's a like a YouTube person but he's
not he's a writer he was a writer in
college he writes for six hours every
single day and he's obsessed about words
so he's worked out what words mean to
him and once he's got that the ground
truth of his reality is always based in
something very very very solid which
means that when he talks about something
he has a first principles approach to
like what do you mean when you talk
about confidence he says well it's not
that but it is this right self-beliefs
overrated generate evidence basically is
his
philosophy there's confidence for you oh
okay well that's interesting but it's
not being swayed he's also somebody that
is highly disagreeable unbelievably
disagreeable which means that he is able
to arrive at conclusions without having
to
think without having to wipe off all of
the opinions of other people quite as
much as someone else might do so it's
very first principles based it's there's
like a degree of Purity which I think uh
people admire like something admirable
about that you did a collaboration with
David gogin one of the very few people
that he finally agrees to go on and
collaborate with I know that that's like
a very rare once in a blue moon thing
what was that like meeting David in
person what was it like before what was
it like after was he very strict with
his time so uh about a week and a half
before we thought the episode wasn't
going to happen happen and then I
basically said like I will move heaven
and earth like if he wants to do it next
week next month next year if he wants me
to go to him if you want me to change
the times I'll do whatever it takes to
make this happen and there was only
Rogan and me that he did for the never
finished tour like the never finish tour
was finished actually quite quickly and
meeting him was was interesting I always
try and look for inconsistencies in
people's behavior like I try and work
out is this person full of [__] and I
got pretty good at doing that like on
the front door of a nightclub you meet I
at a million people so like high
intensity people exposure and however
legit you think David Goggins is like
he's more legit than that the guy is
just
so straight down the line but also in
like very giving so he said before we
started that however long it takes I I
basically there had been some
restrictions maybe in his calendar and
like some scheduling email before and I
was like hey man like I heard that you
might have you got hard out today and
he's like like I'm here for as long as
you need me oh by the way you can ask
anything you want nothing is off limits
we can go anywhere that you want it's
like oh [__] okay and then I asked him a
question obviously he'd had this um like
very bad childhood with his father
physically abusing him and and stuff
like that and I said do you see it as
part of your role um to not let that go
onto the Next Generation you know if you
were to have a a child would you choose
not pass that down you're kind of like a
a dam that stops this intergenerational
mistreatment going on and he didn't need
to but he just said I've got a daughter
he's got like a 22y old daughter and he
just said it on the podcast and didn't
need to but just did so yeah he's he's a
very very legit human like people want
to find ways that he's full of dog [__]
or whatever like I would I would believe
that all of the things that he said he's
done he's done now where they're coming
from and like how health the motivations
are and whether or not there would be a
a quicker route to him achieving the
outcomes that he might want without like
blowing his his knee cartilage out and
all the rest of the stuff like but
that's not his Solution that's not the
way that he works he's a guy who is just
built by like forged by discomfort and
that's the solution that he's found so I
have a theory on this and I want to know
your opinion I think it would be really
valuable certain people do things that
by the General Public they would
probably ascribe the word extremely
uncomfortable to those things so for
example like Graham Works non-stop we
just did a shoot uh we flew somewhere
where were we New York and we shot two
episodes uh we were off a very bad sleep
and the entire flight back he was
working the entire time and I was my
brain was dead I couldn't work MH a lot
of people would see that and be like
dang Graham that's extremely challenging
Kudos too you're a very hard worker you
put yourself you put yourself in very
uncomfortable situations same thing goes
for David goggin goes and just on a whim
decides to run 100 miles right for no
apparent reason at all he just wants to
put himself through this discomfort I
have a theory that it would be more
challenging and more uncomfortable for
someone like David to sit and do nothing
for a week absolutely I mean what would
happen if you took like if all internet
access was killed for you for a week so
so I might like it if the internet is
out then it's out of my oh okay if it's
something I can control that's different
if it's like the internet's out and I
can fix it I'm going to fix it
I now become a Wi-Fi engineer for the
next seven days I'll but the point being
it's like it's it's applauded because
it's hard and it yields a positive
result y but the same thing goes if he
goes and not works for a solid week or
something like that he's challenging
himself and putting himself in voluntary
suffering correct in the same way so for
him it's easy for David it's easy it's
comfortable to go around 100 miles maybe
not right he would probably argue the
contrary what are your thoughts on that
people always choose things that are
difficult but usually within their
control right like you're totally right
the crossfitter that says I'm going to
send it this is an unbelievably hard
workout double day trainings triple day
trainings whatever but if you were to
tell them that oh you need to lie on the
couch for two weeks there's a degree of
discomfort outside of their accepted
zone of comfort right like they can get
it's I mean it's literally the tagline
of CrossFit get comfortable being
uncomfortable so yeah I mean people have
things that they do that are hard that
other people applaud them for and in
retrospect they give them props for like
that's exactly where people find the
intersection of what they love to do
what Society needs what they can be paid
for and what they're good at right like
that's literally the middle of the ven
diagram that's what they're trying to
aim for but do you think that it would
be productive for your own personal
growth and development to step outside
of that and do something that is
extremely uncomfortable that may not be
seen as something that's productive or
rewarding I guess it goes both ways so
for the person who loves working is it
good for them to put themselves in disc
Comfort by not working and for people
that don't work is it worth it for them
to try to do something uncomfortable by
working it's a good question man like a
muscle to e is that even worthwhile to
like try the sake of try well I mean you
know you could put yourself through a
lot of discomfort by sticking pins into
the back of your hand like is there
anything good on the back of it what
we're looking for is an effort to return
ratio and what are the returns that
you're looking for like just arbitrarily
doing hard things for no reason at all
you know let's say that um
you are a protect a competitive
powerlifter and you decide to also start
running 5Ks on a weekend like that would
be hard especially if you're 300 and
used to deadlifting all the time that
would be really difficult for you but it
doesn't actually contribute to the
result that you're looking to try and
get now if there's some anciliary
benefit where oh well by running 5Ks it
teaches me it gets me out of my own head
or it helps improve my HRV or it gives
me time away from the gym or it does
whatever like those things oh yeah
that's interesting I would be interested
to find out like what the person that
lies on the couch for two weeks would
get but I do think that it's just useful
and humbling to remind us all that the
thing that you do that you think is
really really hard is usually something
that you've chosen to do that's really
really hard it's within your control by
Def defined by the fact that you chose
to do it and most people don't broaden
that scope as much as they think and I
don't even know if you need to like you
have a goal you're doing a thing that is
an intermediary between here and there
just keep moving through the idea would
just to be questioning your goals and to
get a fair assessment of like how happy
are you truly right so if like a big
part of Who David goggin is is going and
doing these incredibly challenging
things from an outsider perspective I
should say um questioning that and
trying to chill out and do something and
seeing what life is like on the other
end and also voluntary suffering I think
it's very important for people to put
themselves through well it's the the
question would be how how much is David
going to enjoy the other thing but we
don't know until it's challenged the
part that makes David I think you know
you know what you know you know what you
like you know until you try something
different I look forward to you telling
David that he needs to spend more time
on the couch and seeing how that goes
Jack tells me all the time he's like y
gra you're working a little too much you
should just takes some time off and I
tell Jack dude you're taking too much
time off you got to be working a little
more but the thing is like recently
Graham has been taking a little bit more
of a backseat approach to his whole
career
and he's been drawing and painting and
he's been thoroughly enjoying it and
this is something that he would have
never considered outside of the scope of
his daily life are you trying to get
better at drawing and painting are you
taking classes are you follow no I'm
learning on YouTube to be honest with
you so one of my friends did a training
course thing of some kind he's got a
coach yeah and the coach said that he
needed to do something that he thought
he would enjoy but would suck at and
painting turned out to be that thing and
he gave a caveat which is but you're not
allowed to try and get better at it
because what he wanted to do was just do
something for the sake of enjoying doing
the thing not do something so that oh
well if I get a coach if I get a
painting coach and then actually what's
the exact best kind of brushes that I
need to it's like that's just another
[__] Pursuit you know what I mean
that's not a restorative practice that's
you just becoming obsessive about a new
thing and adding and layering that on
top I was talking to Alex about this
thing yesterday as well which is [__]
awesome it's like 15 years old it's
called 100 days of rejection so every
day for 100 days you do something
different that you're almost certainly
going to get rejected for one of them is
ask for a free coffee so you get to the
end of the line in Starbucks and they
say that's £1 please and you go can I
have this for free I I would just do
that regardless and just see what happen
oh yeah true Finance bro um but then 100
days of that and it just made me really
think oh yeah that's that's that's a
really interesting way to get over some
of the uh predisposition that we have
that we really don't like but yeah um I
would be interested to see what happens
if David Goin spends spends two weeks on
the couch I don't know what goes on it
could be transform imagine if he just
does a 180 it's like guys I'm done with
everything chips and
reality reality TV just goes full
Charlie hoopet and starts taking
psychedelics and playing Dungeons and
Dragons on an evening time yeah you had
mentioned that you had gotten really
good at reading people as a club
promoter how do you read people on what
signs do you look for and what could the
average person take from that to imply
in their own life we looking for in
congruities between what somebody says
and the way that they act so paying
attention is the first thing um I did a
podcast a while ago long time ago like
five years ago with this guy that I was
kind of interested in was curious about
for a while I don't know if I respected
him or not but he was an interesting guy
and we' done this entire episode and
there just little sort of glimmers of
like narcissist bed post came in a
little bit a lot of lot of stories that
didn't need to be brought back toward
him were and then at the very very end
of the episode after we finished
recording I said uh dude just wanted to
say like you know followed your stuff
for a while and you know really it was
really great to meet you and there was
this sort of half microsc like flash
where obviously his ego got really
really inflated and then he Ted it back
down again because he didn't want to
show me that what I'd said had inflated
his ego and I was like huh I don't trust
you I don't trust you you're trying to
play the strange role and it wasn't
coming out of some degree of
vulnerability or whatever it was like
I've got friends that are [__] at taking
compliments it wasn't that there's
people
who play a role because they're trying
to get something on the other side and
those a people that you need to be
really concerned about for like I
struggle to be myself I'm still
discovering what that means to actually
be myself that's a process of discovery
and I'm trying my best to move forward
toward that thing there are other people
who want you to see them in a certain
way because they want a particular
outcome and everything below that is
contrived and those are people that you
need to be really concerned about paying
attention to body language paying
attention
to rigorously scrutinizing whether or
not the things that they said previously
align with the things that they're
saying now that's interesting because
you said that thing there but this seems
to really contradict what you just said
and you haven't called that out and you
said that with loads of certainty and
you're saying this with loads of
certainty like just be really the strong
beliefs loosely held not loose beliefs
strongly held like be concerned about
anyone who says everything with
conviction MH like you should have some
degree of caveat or uncertainty just
baked into the system of you there's uh
you know Peter Zion you know him no
geopolitics expert fascinating guy being
on the show not I don't have the
geopolitical expertise to be able to
assess how accurate he is about all of
these things but that man has the most
conviction of anyone I've ever heard
like just [__] everything is the way
that it is this is the way that this
thing is and I was just famous of being
so seduced by this the the way that he
put things across and if he's right and
if what he's saying is backed up with
the stats below and I have no reason to
presume that it's not I'm like wow like
that is the way that you want to get
this thing across there was no ifs ands
or butts there was no caveats there was
no nothing it's like this is the way
that this thing is but if someone who
maybe knows the industry is able to be
that convincing someone who doesn't is
also able
to create a simulacrum of that like to
do the posturing thing without any of
the research done before so you just
need to be really really careful about
people like that how are you cautious
about people coming onto your show and
saying certain things with super high
conviction on something that maybe you
haven't researched a bunch and you can't
really fight that perspective because
we've had people on this podcast before
um for one fresh and fit they came on
the show they were saying a bunch of
things about dating that we had no idea
about they have all these statistics and
studies and resources and Etc we can't
combat that because we don't have the
data at what point do you draw a line do
you think that you need to know the
other person's argument inside and out
to have them on your podcast that's
unrealistic like you're always going to
be the most stupid person in the room
when it comes to pretty much any topic
unless it's your wheelhouse like someone
comes on and starts talking about like
real estate in Las Vegas and you're like
hey la la like step into the step into
the [__] ring my friend like step
into my office um it's unrealistic to
expect anybody that hosts a general show
to be an expert in any of those things
in my experience like if you give people
enough rope they'll end up hanging
themselves like people will say things
they're like I don't feel like that's
true and if you've got an even remotely
smart audience they're able to
scrutinize that stuff for themselves now
it's your job to say things like huh
like where'd you get that from like what
stats that what is that is that a Pew
research is that GSS data that's
interesting hm and
like what ways might you be wrong like
here's a few things right to work out
whether or not the Creator that you are
slightly skeptical about or anybody that
you follow me included is telling the
truth when was the last time that they
publicly admitted that they were
wrong when was the last time that they
changed their mind on something when was
the last time that they surprised you
with a take like R versus Wade happens
and you go wow wasn't expecting that
that's interesting or Israel Palestine
occurs or Ukraine or buck like some
lizzo's in the news and you go huh that
that's a surprising take from that
that's interesting even if it's like not
something that you agree with but it
wasn't what you predicted and the reason
that that's important is it shows that
they're thinking for themselves and you
can have high conviction that that
person is actually doing some work as
opposed to again the mono thinking just
let's put this ideology on as a onesa
and just proceed forward like that's not
what you want the problem is you can't
really argue with anecdotal experience
so if they come on and they say we've
spoken with 2,000 women and from our
experience that we've seen firsthand
this has been true in the overwhelming
case and I could say well maybe that's
not a scientific study but from your
perspective that works from my
perspective uh you know my experience
works and then there becomes a bit of a
stalemate to whoever sounds more
confident wins and it seems like it no
matter what you talk about whoever's
more confident even if they're wrong
wins the argument in the eyes of the
audience or wins the debate fluency is a
proxy for truthfulness
H right if someone is able to just
deploy words in a slick manner it's the
classic like salesman charlatan that
like encourages you to get your drive
paved even though you don't need it
doing it's like oh it'll protect from
the frost and blah blah blah blah blah
so I mean with that there are certain
things that you could do you could ask a
question like do you think that um the
show that you're doing is swayed At All
by being in Miami and by you sourcing a
lot of the girls from a city which is
known for uh partying and and stuff like
that like we did ask that yeah what did
they and they said no we fly out women
from all AC around the
world of education but the selection
criteria is still
usually they've asked to come on to this
sort of a show it's the same with Brian
and the whatever podcast right like it's
the same that cohort of women there is a
very spec I don't know what the unifying
thing is and it's not like there's a
single unifying thread that ties them
all together but there will be a number
of things that motivate girls and to go
on these sorts of shows so you it's the
same reason what makes someone comment
like why YouTube comment threads always
kind of the same they always have the
same tenor well we don't know what
causes someone to be motivated to
comment but we know that it's happened
to all of these people and there can't
be an unlimited number of things because
it's like out of hundreds of thousands
of views only a very small number of
people comment okay so there's something
which is a selection criteria which
encourages those people to comment the
same thing goes for that but yeah with
anecdotal experience and stuff like that
you're oh well that's interesting that
that's the way that you see it but for
me in my experience that doesn't seem to
be the case like do you think but asking
people like what ways might you be wrong
when was the last time that you admitted
that you're wrong when was the last time
you changed your mind when was the last
time that you said something that
surprised your audience in terms of a
take those are really good ways so I
want to turn that back on you when was
the last time you were wrong about
something I've had a couple of big ones
so for a while I was parting I was
regurgitating GSS dated from 2018 from
2008 2018 the number of men that
reported not having sex in the last 12
months age between 18 and 30 went from
8% to 28% right so massive increase new
GSS data came out and it completely
reversed that Trend it's like way fewer
men were sexless so I put a post out on
Twitter and I was like I was wrong about
this I've been quoting old data I didn't
see the 2019 data and the 2020 data was
skewed because it was covid the 21 22
and I think 23 not sure if that's out
yet that the trend doesn't seem to be
there anymore I'm all right well this is
interesting this shows that something
else is going on uh I was very Pro
hormonal birth control for a long time
came out of the nightlife industry a lot
of casual sex so on and so forth like
you don't want people to be having uh
unwanted kids and then there is like
some real nasty [__] lurking in hormonal
birth control that impacts uh girls
psychological Behavior their
physiological Behavior Uh their
preference for mates [__] have you seen
any of this do you know what I'm talking
about can you go into this because it
seems a lot more prevalent it seems as
though the Tik Tok algorithm has taken
this and has just birth control yeah
birth control um and has just magnified
it and I'm not sure I I have a really
tough time telling the difference
between what's being magnified on social
media and what's coming out from Harvard
and Yale studies on this and and it
seems as though the stuff sounds really
good on Tik Tok it sounds really good
and you know but then I'm research I'm
actually doing some research on this for
like Harvard studies and it says well
yeah this is true but when you look at
it in context it's not a big deal like I
think one of them was it increases the
rate of a certain type of cancer by like
200% and the Harvard study says yeah
well it goes up 200% because it's like
one rate is so 500,000 people gets it
and now it's like two and in a big it's
not like that big of a deal yeah so what
is your perspective Dr Sarah Hill wrote
a brook wrote a book uh this is your
brain on birth control and that's kind
of the One-Stop shop for this as far as
I can see she's an evolutionary
psychologist uh there are some things to
be worried about like when it comes to
especially young girls taking hormonal
birth control it can lock in a certain
type of protein folding in the brain
that predisposes them to anxiety and
depression for the rest of their life
even if they then choose to come off so
these formative years of brain
development seem to be particularly
susceptible to these sorts of drugs and
what age is that uh throughout puberty I
think for girls um so you know let's say
age 12 to 18 or something like that
would it solve it to start birth control
let's say at 25 when a brain's developed
well you would at least I think evade
that issue which is this sort of lock in
and it's this isn't for every single
case but there's a risk of that
happening um I mean there's some pretty
good evidence that suggests that women
on hormonal birth control opt for
different types of men they opt for uh
providers rather than protectors so they
tend to deprioritize the mascul it of
the men that they're dating and they
tend to over optimize for their ability
to provide for them so levels of wealth
and uh academic achievement one of the
things that everybody that's listening
to this if you're in a relationship with
a girl who's on birth control or if
you're a girl who's on birth control and
you're thinking about getting engaged
come off birth control for six months
and see if you still love your partner
this sounds so stupid right if you want
to have well it's such a great match and
all the rest of it but your hormones
literally create the physics of your
system like the the internal experience
is completely dictated very largely
dictated by the hormonal Pro profile
that your body is going through and
every girl listening to this knows
because what's it like when it's that
time of the month and what's it like
when it's not you know that your mood
and the way that you feel wax and Wayne
but birth control is something that's
just this sort of permanent underline
that you can't you can almost not
remember what it was like before that uh
so that's something else that people
should be concerned about
because there's an awful lot of data
from natural cycles I think it's called
Uh which is like a cycle tracking
thermometer that you put under your
tongue so that you know when you're
ovulating and when you're not as a woman
it links up with your phone and all this
stuff and uh women who met their partner
when they were on birth control and are
now off birth control have the same
level of sex drive but much lower levels
of attraction to their partner the women
who met them when they were off and
they're now still off so they're
selecting for a type of mate that when
they get released from this hormone
induced stuper are not quite what they
want and this can be like how many
relationships have fallen down the pan
that someone's gone through six years of
dating then they get engaged then they
get married then let's try and have a
kid and you stop taking birth control
and you're like huh part of me thinks
how many variables are there though I
mean just getting to the point of you
know getting married to someone you've
been with them for a long time at what
point does maybe the excitement and
mystery wear off at that point that also
contributes to that having a child is
that a a stressful thing I think 30% of
uh pregnancies and in a miscarriage what
toll does that take I think there's so
many things coming down on people it
could also be the pressure to have kids
after getting married you know when all
the comments from Friends uh and family
so how could we isolate it to just birth
control well that's that's precisely
what natural cycles did right they've
isolated the other variables my point is
that that path of Engagement marriage
then come off is very typical I think uh
so you have this uh coinciding of
reduction of birth control and then huh
but that's what natural cycles precisely
did how attracted to your partner are
you like level of sex drive was the same
between women who met when they were on
and are now off and women who met when
they were off and an now off but the
level of satisfaction with their sex
life was significantly lower which
suggests that there is something about
mate selection under the condition of
hormonal birth control which is
suboptimal when you then come out of it
on the other side regardless of
relationship status regardless of how
long been together regardless of marital
all the rest of the stuff that's
something so that was something else
that I was pretty wrong about what else
I have uh last year was epigenetics like
I thought epigenetics was dog [__] I
thought it was like the god of the gaps
of like behavioral genetics and I
thought that what do you mean you
telling me that like my behavior changes
my genes and downstream from that it's
going to impact like my kids when I have
kids like the way that I behave like no
that's it's just it's raw DNA data and
that's it but since having a bunch of
conversations this year Dr Robert
sapolsky Dr Paul Conti I am on board
with that like women who enter poverty
during pregnancy negatively impact the
trajectory like natal development gets
negatively impacted compared with women
who don't because being in poverty is
such a huge stressor and it's very hard
to get out of it you're always thinking
about where's the next rent payment
coming from and so on and so forth and
here's the ruthless thing while a woman
has a daughter inside of her remember
that every female baby is born with all
of the eggs that she will have for the
entirety of her life so a girl's
behavior and her genetic predisposition
can be influenced by the way that her
grandmother was living her life when she
was pregnant with her mother does that
make sense that's
crazy wild absolutely wild that's
something I've never even thought of
before yeah yeah yeah so while that
grandmother is pregnant you have this
growing girl inside and that girl has
every egg that she's ever going to be
able to give birth to so you like first
second generation person down are at the
mercy of what grandma did while she was
pregnant and what she did throughout her
life it's wild man so behavioral
genetics that was probably the one from
three and a bit years ago I'm big into
agency I like being able to believe that
I can take control of my life I like
through sheer will being able to make
changes to the things that I do and yet
50% of everything that you are
psychologically is based on your
genetics have you have a look at have
you seen Ty Lopez was very big on this
and we had a really interesting
discussion with him about how much of
you is genetic versus how much of you is
the environment and Tai I think even
took it to an extreme and said that
almost all of you is genetic and that
you're going to get a lot of the same
traits from your parents and
grandparents um very little is actually
influenced by that around you all right
so I want to do an experiment with you
so uh I'm going to give you a bunch of
traits right different things and you
are going to tell me the difference how
much are these traits influenced by
genetics and this is out of Dr Robert
plowman's book blueprint okay okay so
what percent do you
think this is influenced by genetics eye
color
100% yeah 100%
95%
height 100% say 85%
80% weight
50%
H 65% 70% so
70% of why you weigh what you weigh can
be explained by genetics now this isn't
to say if you get born on a desert
island where there's no food guess what
like you're going to be thin but on
average 70% of your BMI correlates with
your parents and they've done this the
way that they've been able to do this is
by do by doing twin studies that are
separated at Birth so you manage to keep
the genetics the same but put them into
different environments so let's keep
going okay breast cancer oh I have no
idea 60%
10% stomach
ulcers 30% 70% schizophrenia oh that's
that's got to be pretty high say 80% 50%
autism I think that's kind of
genetically 35 70 oh I say I'm sorry
yeah uh School
achievement 60% I would say low 60% okay
all verbal
ability eight no 40% 70 60 remembering
faces oh my gosh so 70% 80 60% spatial
ability like
navigation say 60 I'm GNA say 80 70% and
the big one general intelligence IQ oh
wow they have data on this 85% say 75
50% but by the end of life your IQ
correlates with your parents 80% wow so
that's all the school all the prep work
all the nutrition all the late nights
all the reading all the coaching all the
everything for
20% that's unbelievable remembering that
height is 80% how is height 80 % is that
is that also like your diet of course
and stuff like that of course of course
so how well how how well fed are you how
well rested are you think about all of
the things that impact like I think
sleep correlates with height actually
quite significantly almost definitely
but so are you saying I could
theoretically be taller had I eaten
better and slept more yeah but what if I
did both of those perfectly and I still
end up at the do you think then I would
be even shorter so uh yeah maybe you you
might be at the upper bracket of exactly
how tall you can be but this is the
interesting thing right and this is why
people that learn about behavioral
genetics become despondent yeah the
reason is they realize that there is a
bracket that they exist within and that
no matter how well you'd eaten and all
the rest of it something tells me that
you couldn't have got yourself to 66
right so oh my god there are
restrictions placed and in a world
that's a meritocracy that feels unfair
it's like hang on I I thought I was
supposed to be able to be anything that
I wanted to be I'm big into agency I
don't like the fact feeling like the
world happens to me I want to happen to
the world so people feel sometimes
disempowered by that it's difficult
Destiny was the guy that actually framed
this the best for me which is there is a
range that you can exist within and that
is usually determined by things that are
outside of your control but within that
range it's all down to you exclusively
down to you so your personality is 50%
inherited by your parents including your
happiness set point is around about 50%
genetically determined boo that means
that 50% of me is genetically determined
well yay that also means that 50% is in
your hands now how much of that truly is
genetic versus being brought up by your
parents who act a certain way genetic
genetic outright genetics predisposition
and they've done this by separating out
so you get you get two twins and they're
adopted into different
households you have let's say one that
gets adopted by a family which is quite
fat and one that's adopted by a family
which is at a healthy
BMI neither of them correlate with their
adoptive parents both of them correlate
with their birth parents despite the
fact that they've never lived with them
why well because there are lots of
different things that influence the way
that you go about the world like what if
your gin release is just High that's the
hunger hormone what if you really don't
like exercise all that much what if you
need more sleep to feel rested all of
these things are going to contribute to
you being the sort of person that is
going to gain weight more
easily living in an environment where
you learn healthy habits and all the
rest of it yeah these things are
important and amazing but the most
important decision that you can make for
your future child's outcomes in life
happiness and everything else is who you
choose to have them with and not because
they're going to influence the
environment that they live in they will
do that which is super important and
shouldn't be Mis mated but mostly
because they create the raw materials
that this person is going to be built
out of there's this great story from
aland Boton where he talks about the
trajectory over time of
the ancient world to the modern world so
in the ancient times the people that
were the Beggars on the streets would be
referred to as the unfortunates lady
Fortuna hadn't blessed them and the
reason that lady Fortuna holds this set
of scales is that she gives and she
takes away right they were seen to be a
scale that somehow balanced the
unfortunates on the street now who is
someone that doesn't fulfill their
dreams they're a
loser right it's no longer because lady
Fortuna hadn't blessed them and because
they're a a large blend of different
ways that people can come into this
world it's because if winners in a
meritocratic system are worthy of their
successes the people that lose they're
also worthy of their losses and we all
know that people that try hard and
continue to do things in an effective
manner get great
outcomes
but it's a hard Circle to square as a
bunch of people that want to say I'm in
control and yet there are things that
are outside of my control and some of
those are genetically determined like
this is really difficult and it's messy
and I still haven't found like my
position on like how do you Empower
people how do you teach them about
behavioral genetics and say that 50% of
your personality including your
conscientiousness your industriousness
your neuroticism your openness to new
experience all of those things your
political ideology is like 50%
influenced by your parents your politics
how do you teach someone that and then
still give them this sense of agency
over their own life it's a difficult
Circle to square but it's one that that
was 2020 that was like the thing that
kind of like came and hit me in the back
of the head and like 2021 was maybe
birth control and then 2022 was
epigenetics or whatever so how do you
approach that with if I'm assuming maybe
one day you want kids like who you would
have kids with and what do you look for
in that and do you approach it in the
same way that you approach this data and
just say like you know I want someone
who is you know all this down the less
so that my kids have the highest chance
of being like the best that they could
be I think the best piece of advice and
this is from PL as well is choose
carefully like choose carefully choose
your partner very carefully and that's
not just for some utilitarianism macki
ofan raw genetic data thing right it's
that you need to spend the rest of your
life with this person and if you care
about your kids it's going to be 50% of
you you know that it's going to be 50%
of you the other
50% you get to you get to choose what
that's going to
be one of of the best things I think
that everybody should look for in a
partner and this is pretty much
Universal is something called
psychological stability pretty
self-explanatory but the best way to
gauge it it's kind of hard to do the
best way to gauge it is after you've had
a disagreement or um an emotional
perturbant of some kind how long does it
take for them to get back to Baseline
just get back to normal if it takes them
a day and a half that's not someone
that's not particularly psychologically
stable because things are going to
continue to happen you can't stop the
psychological perversions coming in you
can just deal with them more quickly
like if there's an incident if something
happen you're late for a a a flight or
something like that and that's the rest
of the holiday completely wrecked
because this person simply can't get
over it that is going to be a very
difficult relationship and it's very
poorly predictive of relationship
satisfaction so psychological stability
is not only something that you should
select in other people but it's
something that you should aim to
cultivate in yourself it's going to make
you a better partner it's going to make
you a more attractive partner it's going
to actually improve your own life as
well like the most altruistic selfish
thing that you can do and make myself
better and enjoy my experience of life
and it's also going to help make you
better as well but yeah when it comes to
choosing a partner like you have to
choose carefully so what if you pick
someone that's not super psychologically
stable but you both work together to
improve that yeah well that's the
Michelangelo effect which is in a
relationship both Partners craft each
other into their desired version I see
in you the person that you could be and
I help to bring it out of you and you
help to bring it out of me and together
we become something which is even better
that's what you want from a partner
which is why having a growth mindset is
another one of the best predictors right
like somebody that believes that they
can change and someone that's prepared
to work at changing and help you to
change as well you're essentially
unbeatable right because any problem
that you come up against it's okay how
hard do we need to work at this in order
to be able to overcome it now if the
thing is we need to be able to get gahe
to like 6 fo six like that's going to be
very difficult thing to get to but there
are presumably that's not going to be
one of the challenges that you need to
try and get over so you like might
though yeah well you know people are
going to Turkey and getting their legs
chopped in half so that they can get
femur extensions or whatever it is so
there's something that goes on there
quick side tangent what do you think of
that surgery by the way I've seen gnarly
videos on this it's wild dude it makes
me feel sad like it makes me feel sad
that we have got to a stage where the
culture has convinced men maybe in some
regards rightly but I think it's been
overblown that height is one of it's so
important to your outcomes in life that
this super dangerous dangerous very new
very experimental surgery is something
that you should go for because it's
extending I'm pretty sure it extends the
shin both and the femur yes so they
break both of them and they could extend
both I think it's like three in each so
you can get six in of height yeah it's
it's pretty substantial now I
because I I I don't want to say I looked
into this but I was very curious and I
went down the rabbit hole of exactly
like how much it costs like I wouldn't
do it hundreds of thousands of dollars
depending on what you want to do I think
the cheapest ones are like 50 60 but it
also depends BR if you're getting the
[__] if you're getting the cheap leg
extension that's not where you should be
SC it's not cheap it's it's cheap in the
sense of like it's it's a big difference
increasing your height by an inch than
it is by six inches and the because you
basically separate you break the bone
and you separate it just a little bit
gross and you kind of let it heal you
break it again separate it let it heal
but it's breaking it in such small
segments that over time it could be over
years then you get taller so like the
more height you want the more expensive
it's going to be what if your torso is
already short and like all of your
Heights in your legs and then all of a
sudden you turn into like a SpongeBob or
something like that where like you know
your legs are like 5et tall in your
torso is like a foot and a half I don't
think people are doing that well if
you're adding 6 in
May that's an extreme that's an extreme
but who's to say you can't add 5 in or 4
in or 3 in your your arms are going to
be like what would that be like hanging
super low so like so I'm a good example
of this my torso is the same as Macy's
her legs are longer than mine so like
I'm losing height because of my legs so
I I think some people yeah you know
their legs might be long torso really
small but I think for a lot of people
it's mostly in the legs it's just a I
mean you know it seems like height is
one of the things that women want like
on average women want to date a man
that's 21 cm taller than they are and
what is that in inches like seven seven
inches taller no that can't be right
what's 21 centimeters and inches no that
actually sounds about right 8.26 what on
average men want to date a woman that's
on average 16 cmet shorter than they are
which would be like four and a half I
think uh now again like this is it's a
little while since that date has come
out so it may have upd a little bit but
like the bottom line is that guys
understand what is it I think out of
every presidential election only one of
them hasn't been won by the taller
candidate interesting almost like some
insane disproportionate number of CEOs
and millionaires are over six foot heard
right that can't be a coincidence well I
heard that if you're over a certain
height you're like 7% more likely to
make over six figures a year like
there's so many correlations it seems
with um income and height and confidence
and height and respect and height and
authority and height there's I think
there's a lot of things which directions
this going in is the question is it that
tall people are sufficiently confident
that they can ask for that raise and be
commanding or is it that because the the
world respects tall people in a way that
they just give stuff to them I think is
a second because it's also with
attractiveness that attractive people
tend to get their way more and they tend
to yeah exactly and they tend to make
more money because they get more
opportunities because they are
attractive one of the big things that no
one really ever talks about is uh
dominance and intimidation so it seems
like a lot of what men are optimizing
for isn't necessarily attractiveness
it's their ability to intimidate other
men so there's this really really
interesting study done by David putz and
they brought uh men and women into the
lab to look at photos and videos of guys
and they asked the women how attractive
they thought were and asked the men How
likely they thought it would be that
they could beat that man in a fight 12
months later they assessed the men that
were on the iPad and asked them how many
sexual partners that they'd had the
female rating of facial attractiveness
had zero predictive ability in how many
mates they had but the man's
intimidation metric was very correlated
so men who are most successful in The
Mating Marketplace at least in that
regard are doing doing it through
dominance rather than through attraction
so a lot of the things that guys like um
when men are in the presence of other
women and other men they lower their
voice because a lower voice larger voice
box uh vocal folds is a sign of uh High
Androgen response so like more
aggression and being bigger like just
being bigger is good and protective for
you so David the same guy told me about
when he was in graduate school and he
was waiting at the checkout to be served
a supermarket and he could hear these
two guys behind him and they were
speaking super low and he thought oh my
God like the jazz singers behind me as
this two old men he turned around and it
was two guys that were around about his
age you know like early 20s or something
but in between him and them was a really
hot girl and both of these guys's voices
were super low because that's this sort
of posturing thing but you also see it
very interestingly um men when they're
in communication with other men that
they think are more intimidating or
dominant than they are they they'll
actually add they'll raise their voice
up a little bit and they'll speak around
about here and that's because don't you
don't need to worry about me I'm not I'm
not going to threaten you at all and
it's just baked into the way that we see
the world like we don't want to get on
the wrong side of the hard guy that
might piss us off I'm one of your allies
you don't need to worry about me but you
got nothing to worry about but it's not
always the same when it's the reverse
and for the sexual partners I think you
saying dominance was a big correlation
on that M or intimidation couldn't those
be the people though that are more
likely to make moves and like more
likely to go up and talk to the girl
this is only the way that they look this
is literally just the way that they look
no I understand that but when you say
when you come back a year later and you
you correlate that to how many partners
they've had the people who looked a
little bit or the people that were more
what were we saying more intimidating
they looked so the the men said do you
think that you could beat this person in
a fight right that was the and the more
people that did say that they could beat
him in a fight presumably they look less
intimidating fewer people that did
presuming they look more intimidating
it's just the interesting thing is that
you think oh my God how is like male
ratings of intimidation more predictive
than female ratings of attractiveness
like how is that how does that work and
it just seems like I mean Peterson's
talked about this for ages right that
you have a dominance hierarchy where the
men compete between each other and then
the women pick off the top okay and
that's why wealth is the best mating
game ever created because it's one
single unitary number that's like oh
that's how competent you are women don't
care about the
money some care about the money most
women aren't in it for the money what
they're in it for is the predictor that
allows men to achieve that amount of
money which is their competence and
their hard work and all the rest of the
stuff this what I think about the gym
like most people think that going to the
gym and building a big body is it's just
about the way that you look but I think
the signal of I'm someone that is able
to make sacrifices I'm someone that's
reliable I'm somebody that cares about
themselves I'm someone that can overcome
hard things I'm someone that can deal
with discomfort and pain that's kind of
sexy like Upstream from you being in
good shape are all of these other traits
that people probably want in a partner
right that's why like it's do you know
the difference between proximate and
ultimate reasons for Behavior no [__]
awesome such a good frame okay so um the
approximate reason for having sex is sex
feels good the ultimate reason for
having sex is we make babies right so
there is a outcome that you looking to
get and there is a motivation for why
you do the thing um why do we eat sugary
fatty foods because it tastes good
approximate what is the reason our body
wants us to eat those they are calorie
dense and usually rare in ancestral
environments so approximate and ultimate
reasons for behavior and as soon as the
veils fall from your eyes and you
realize that the reason that you think
that you do a thing often isn't the
reason that you actually do the thing
and that you've got this sort of set of
genes that are pulling the strings and
marting you that's why I think
evolutionary psychology there the two
most banned or the two
most distasteful subjects in all of
psychology and this was an email sent to
every psychology professor in the the us
and not everyone replied uh the two
topics that you shouldn't speak about
the most as rated by psychologists in
universities professors in America
behavioral genetics and evolutionary
psychology they were the two why
because it takes the sense of
self-authorship out of your hands it
proves that people aren't infinitely
malleable and in a meritocracy that's
something that people really don't like
any kind of determinism whether it be
genetic in terms of somebody's sex in
terms of somebody's uh race in terms of
somebody's background in terms of
somebody's anything they hate that idea
and that's got weaponized by like some
pretty [__] nasty philosophies but
there's also a ton of of ground truth in
it and like telling you the only reason
that you aren't a basketball player
that's 6'6 is because of something that
you did is not true and unfair and
disempowering but like feeding someone
Chicken Soup for the Soul and saying no
no no no like you you you you can get
there and the reason is because of
something that it's this structural
issue or this whatever I don't think
that that makes people feel more
empowered I think it makes them
ultimately feel more fatalistic that's
is he that in Academia they were
optimizing for empowerment rather than
truth part it sounds so contradictory I
could see a perspective where they think
we're not going to teach people that
they can't be in Direct Control of their
life and that we want everyone to
believe that they have a chance at
achieving whatever there's they've set
out to do and that maybe there's some
some power to that and making people
believe that they could do anything that
they want to and not feeling restricted
like saying I can never be a doctor
because my parents are not smart and
therefore I destined to be dumb and why
should I even try because both my
parents they they never amounted to
anything they're stupid so I can never
do that like what what does that serve
Society how is that better I agree but
the converse is also unkind in in a
different kind of a way which is oh the
reason that you didn't become a
basketball player is exclusively because
of you like that's your fault and pick
your other professional outcome
equivalent that people wanted so it's
this is Corey Clark that did this
particular piece of research one of the
other reasons that she puts forward is
that you have an increasingly feminized
uh higher education system very very
high number of two women for every one
man completing a four-year us college
degree within the next couple of years
and then who become the lecturers well
the college students so you are having
an
increasingly female
dominated staff in higher education as
well and if that's the case women tend
based on Cory's research to opt for
things that outcomes that don't make
people feel uncomfortable even if they
have to skew the truth a little bit
whereas male teachers seem to disregard
the way that things make people feel and
optimize for truth instead and this is
where especially behavioral genetics and
evolutionary psychology get get a really
really bad what's the what's the outcome
of that what you're saying is more
female teachers and maybe skewing things
to not make people feel uncomfortable
where does that leave us where do we end
up if that continues at the same at the
same rate you optimize for not
necessarily telling the truth all the
time and there's tons and tons of caveat
caveat caveat like there's lots and lots
of female lectures out there that are
bothered about the truth that prioritize
that and all the rest of it but based on
the data it seems like you begin to skew
toward a world that doesn't want to
upset people and that eventually like
you can't repurpose reality in order to
fit what you want it to be like the
facts are the facts and if you start
trying to couch things ult like it's not
happened but everyone claimed that the
reason that door came off the Boeing jet
a couple of weeks ago was because they'd
had like a ton of diversity highs I'm
not saying that that's I've never heard
of that before there was like a was it
what was it LA to Vegas there was a
flight from LA to Vegas the door coming
off ended there the point the point
being that that that talking point can
be weaponized by look at all of these
diversity highers that's the reason that
you can't make a door stay on a plane
that's not necessarily the truth I'm not
saying that that's the truth but the
point is if you continue to optimize for
making people feel good as opposed to
okay what does reality say you can
imagine where there will be a time where
you need to make a choice between those
two and if the implication is we don't
tell people about this psychological
study it's like probably doesn't matter
if somehow the implication was the door
on the plane doesn't fit right that's a
big deal something tells me that Boeing
is sufficiently smart that that's not
what's going on and also who's to say
that you can't get like perfectly
competent people that are diversity
highs and all the rest of it but yeah
when you optimize for uh not necessarily
telling the
truth and trying to make people feel
good with insights like that you can
quite easily see how it's a slippery
slope that could end up with basically
research not telling you about the world
just telling people what they think they
want to he how could guys increase their
attractiveness the agel question so look
there are some immutable facts about the
way that you
look that you can't change shy of
snapping your legs in Turkey you're not
going to get you're not going to get
much taller I apologize um I think that
some of the easiest ways to do it is to
go to the gym it seems
like a man's ability to protect a woman
which is seen through uh dominance
intimidation um muscularity the Vaper um
those are really really strong
predictors of female attractiveness
female attraction to men so go to the
gym three times a week for a year like
you're in the top percentile of all
Fitness people on the planet if you do
that like that's how low the bar is
right also the average American man is
obese Divorced with less than 1K in the
bank that's the average right that's
such a high B man dude I have no idea
how I'm going to be able to you know
like women don't just want average yo
that's average is that an unrealistic
bar for you get for you to get over
obese divorced less than 1K in the bank
um go to the gym three times a
week I think spend time around places
that have women in low stakes uh
CrossFit gym ping pong Club Buck Club
comedy club like yoga Pates raiki
whatever you are painting watercolors
whatever you're interested in because if
painting if you can finger painting is
that what you're doing no um if you can
have low stakes interactions with women
I think that you will build up the
ability to communicate with them and not
feel the pressure a lot of the time like
Destiny again really great piece of
advice from him like a lot of people
said like how come you seem quite
confident with women despite the fact
that he's not like some you know like
big hulking dude he said I had a lot of
female friends when I was in high school
and college and that resulted in just
learning how to talk to them I think
that for guys just learning that they're
not quite as scary as you think is
really close to a proxy for confidence
like it's not that you're not confident
around women although it might be a lot
of the times just you're [__]
terrified of them and if you can get rid
of the terror the confidence whatever
confidence even if it's a small amount
should Blossom an awful lot it's like
lots of guys are just so scared of
talking to women it's like spend time
around women find a place where your
unique characteristics are an unfair
competitive Advantage so people like
competence right people that are
competent are sexy whether it's man or
woman let's say that you played tennis
when you were a kid for like six years
everyone did some sort of a sport
usually say you played tennis if you go
and play pickle ball now that muscle
memory will kick in and within eight
weeks you'll probably be one of the best
pickle ball players at your local park
or whatever guess what hot chicks in
skirts play pickle ball go play pickle
ball is that true Jack no h i mean but
then again I are you derating the last
pickle ball talent I don't want to say
anything every girl playing pickle ball
in Las Vegas is hanging on every word
here first of all I want to apologize to
all the ladies that play pickle ball at
Sunset Park pickleball complex here in
Vegas uh not my cup of tea I don't find
that there's a lot of girls in skirts
that are attractive playing pickleball
there however move to auson when there
are I would love to maybe when there are
girls that are attractive they're
accompanied by a Harum of men oh
interesting so a lot of the times like I
will see like on the occasion where I do
see an attractive girl there she's got
like six dudes okay that she's playing
so what do you do in that circumstance
do you I go in and I swoop the girl I
say no guys this work on your drive and
drop shot for 6 weeks and then come back
possibly it can't be improved at this
point you could be her friend until she
breaks up with her boyfriend and then
you can get in there that's years that's
a that's a long that's a long play um
yeah so go to the gym uh spend time
around women like you think no one
expects they're going to be good at
doing something without practicing but
one of the weird things about dating is
that there's no such thing as game tape
right you don't get to practice chatting
up a woman it's like the the competition
flaw and the sandbox practice thing are
one and the same so if you can remove
some of the pressure by just like having
conversations with women at work or when
you're at a bar and not trying to chat
them up just being like hey do you see
that whatever whatever think like you're
not there to try and get the outcome
because I think a lot of the time the
the reason that guys get nervous about
trying to talk to women is that they
feel like there's this very binary
success failure thing it's like either I
got her number or I didn't get her
number but what you're looking to do is
accumulate the skill of just
communicating to women in a way that
doesn't make you seem like a weirdo and
you can do that with way less pressure
if you just get rid of the binary of
that oh this is now like actual practice
this is me sandboxing whether or not
this is going to work inhabit places is
where people value your unique talents
right you're really great at yoga like
or you whatever finger painting pickle
ball CrossFit whatever like go do that
thing because people respect people that
are competent and you're going to oh
like yeah Jack's like real good like I
really love the way that he plays pickup
he's yeah he's kind of sexy or he's kind
of whatever like that's the sort of
thing that I think you don't really
think about and everyone has something
that's in there everybody has some of
these unique assets that can be valued
one of the ones for women that I think
is like not spoken about is learning to
be receptive to guys so in a post me2
era let me give you this one 86% of
women say they want a man to make the
first move 76% of men say that they are
terrified of making the first move for
fear of being seen as creepy 20% of gen
Z say that a man approaching a woman in
public always are usually constitutes
harassment square that Circle 86% of
women want a man to make the first move
76% men are terrified of making the
first move so what that means is guys
know if they don't make the first move
nothing's going to happen but that if
they do make the first move they're
going to maybe be seen as creepy and
they're terrified of being me tooed
women know that they want a man to make
the first move but if they like they
only 14% of them are actually going to
go out and do it on their behalf so
women cultivating receptiveness I think
is a good way to do this there was this
idea from uh like Renaissance uh Europe
and the aristocracy in England where
ladies would drop a handkerchief like in
front of them oh Mom Mom and go back
over oh thank Jack thank you so much and
that would begin that would instigate it
I think in a post me to world it's
important for girls to realize that like
guys are on like it's not no means no
it's anything that isn't [__] yeah with
a sign held above their head this is for
any normal respectful guy it's just
terrifying of being on the wrong side of
some like [__] me too drama so like
cultivating receptiveness I think is
something that would make it way easier
for guys to come like treat every guy
like a golden retriever like total idiot
and probably needs like broader signals
than you think that they do linger the
eyes for longer and then yeah they'll
end up eventually coming over this could
be dangerous but what do you think about
the people that say it's only harassment
until you're an attractive guy well I
think it's very shortsighted to presume
that someone who's
looks like Chris hemworth and someone
who looks like a normal guy in the
street is going to get the same reaction
when they go up and start talking to
anybody a guy or a girl
right harassment I think is like at
least in that regard cat calling
whatever yeah but that is like it
doesn't matter whether you're Chris
Hemsworth or not the the culture has now
said that if you wolf whistle at a girl
on the street regardless of who you are
that's beyond the pale if you just treat
people like people and go up to and say
hey I just wanted to say I hope you're
having a really great day and
night I'd like yeah exactly yeah working
it's working it's working already you
RIS me up man um anybody that does that
anybody that responds to that in a way
that this made me feel unsafe presuming
it's not in a dark alley at 11:00 p.m.
at night and you're the only guy with a
hood up or something again like context
matters anybody that has a problem with
that like it's unreasonable Joey swall
did like a a service for the world when
he started calling out those crazy gym
Tik Tok things some girls were saying a
guy glancing over three times in 90
seconds constitutes harassment and that
went out on the internet and the
internet said we don't think it does we
think you're full of [__] so now guys
are like oh okay well there is a I know
that if I glance over no more than three
times in 90 seconds that's probably okay
and girls also think I'm not being
harassed unless the guy glances over
four times in 90 seconds or you know it
created a barometer it created a box for
this sort of a thing but that was the
world saying this hyp sensitive concern
that you have about guys looking over to
you during your training session is
unwarranted and that guy did nothing
wrong like that to me shows that if
someone isn't being creepy for the most
part and yes is this mediated absolutely
are you going to get if you come over
and you're Alan richer from [__]
Reacher like this just jacked dude 6'
five looking like a Greek God are you
going to get more leeway yeah absolutely
of course you're going to get more
leeway but if you just presume
don't do something stupid and don't do
it in a dark alley yeah see I was saying
how much of that is social awareness
where people are losing that touch of
being able to tell if someone else is
uncomfortable there's some situations
that I could just intuitively feel this
person isn't feeling it right now uh
maybe they're not as receptive to what
I'm saying I'm going to back off and
it's just a you know I guess a body
language thing or you just kind of sense
it and it seems like some people are
completely oblivious to this and I could
just I could look at the conversation
say I
know this person's not enjoying the
conversation this person has no idea how
could they not see that but I'm looking
at it's so obvious so do you think it's
just a lack of social awareness that
maybe people are can't pick up on these
cues I think definitely Downstream from
spending a lot of time on social media
and video games and porn and stuff we're
just not as Adept socially like
everyone's become 12-year-old Chris in
some regard right just like I ungainly
and I don't really know what I'm doing
socially and stuff like that and yeah
like flirting especially and making new
friends too it's like a delicate dance
there's this sort of push and pull and
there's like teasing and there's not and
there's you know it's like it's a real
delicate skill to build and if you don't
have that if you're not sufficiently
dextrous with that you can quite easily
find yourself in I didn't I didn't even
mean to do anything wrong what did I do
and it's like people didn't see it
necessarily and it's that that's the
concern that's the fear that people have
people are more clumsy socially than
they've ever been before and the world
is more sensitive to their clumsiness
that if you do something which you
didn't mean in a bad way but it
oversteps some sort of a mark socially
or or romantically or whatever it is
like you're going to know about it it's
the most sensitive we've ever been and
maybe everyone's the most clumsy they've
ever been like it's literally Bull in
China shop not necessarily good what are
some of the red flags you see for dating
when it comes to both men and women
psychological stability is probably the
biggest one but that does take someone
that's psychologically unstable does
does that mean that they're unfit for a
relationship how do they fix that there
has to be some sort of solution well
they can self-regulate right there's no
reason that the person who's
psychologically unstable I'm not saying
like oh
you if you're psychologically unstable
you're Unworthy of a relationship like
that's not my point but what I am saying
is they're ready once they stabilize
well no like I mean dude people again
the Michelangelo fact like people get
into relationships all the time it's not
that they're not going to get into a
relationship it's going to be painful
for the person on the other side of it
and probably them as well right but then
you take a psychologically unstable
person and what does that mean for them
in their dating life does that mean that
they will just continue to get involved
in toxic relationships or how do they
like recognize the fact maybe that they
they should stabilize like are we saying
psychologically unstable as though
they're just not mature enough to
stabilize that it's just how long does
it take them to get back to Baseline
right but let's take someone that takes
a long time M to get back to Baseline so
they're not psychologically if you are
the person that's Cho I would move on
that's what that's what I would say
unless you are like I'm head over heels
with this person I can't like there's
just everything else about them is so
great that I can't not see them as this
phenomenal human
being maybe that's the maybe that maybe
that's the person for you I've got uh an
interesting study here that I want to
take you guys through research has
pulled over a thousand registered us
voters aged 18-34 a majority of both
women and men consider far rightism and
far- leftism to be red flags in a
potential partner 76% of women and 59%
of men consider identifying as a Maga
Republican to be a major turnoff 64% of
men and 55% of women said they'd also
swipe left on someone identifying as a
communist 55% of women said that
listening to Joe Rogan was a red flag
35% for men 41% of women said the same
for a woman being into astrology 20% of
women 33% of men say they say black
lives matter 14% for women 53% of women
for they refuse to see the Barbie move
movie 31% for men so basically there are
lots and lots of very arbitrary rules
that people are putting in place about
dating it's like they listen to Joe
Rogan whatever 50% of women say that
that's a red flag the real ones are
psychological
stability uh for me I think a very
important one is how much do they
value intrinsic versus extrinsic reward
so like are they doing something because
they want to be seen by other people
they want to gain St they want the
Adoration and the validation of the
crowd versus how much they just want to
do things with you for their own reason
like do they want you to be on their arm
as the guy or the girl so that they can
show you off to everyone else or do they
want to be with you in private because
they just love your company like those
are two huge like huge predictors and
you can go down oh does body count
matter and like what's the level of like
actually one other one that I think is
almost like universally agreed on is
what are their um core values like you
can have two people with the same values
and different interests that get into a
great relationship if you don't have the
same values it's almost impossible
because you're permanently going to be
coming into conflict what sorts of
values political ideology would be one
but isn't a political ideology a like on
top of your value system so like the
value syst it's born out of the value
system though right like if you but it
could be misguided it could but then
you're going to have to be like hey have
you ever considered that your far-
leftism isn't actually what you believe
and your basically rehabilitating this
person my belief on dating is that you
meet the person where they are if this
person has got amazing raw materials and
you think I'm pretty convinced that I
can turn this person into the sort of
person that I want them to be and
they're not that far off fantastic but
if you see someone and you're just like
they're hot but crazy and I mean it's a
meme I can fix
her I can fix it it's a [__] super
meane because people know that on
average it's not true like I think meet
people where they're at like try and
find some they don't have to be the
finished article they don't have to be
absolutely perfect but you have to see
something in them where you're like yeah
this is this is good dude if you marry
somebody you have strong political views
and their political views don't align
with yours you're in for a rough ride
you're in for a really rough ride
because it's born out of your values
it's like what do you think about the
sanctity of life like let's say that
someone gets pregnant like you're
literally going to have that argument
front and center at least if you guys
both agree you're not going to have that
conflict on top of what is already a
pretty like difficult conversation that
you're going to have about what's going
to go on the same thing goes
for literally everything else in your
life like do we think that our kids
should go to private school or be
homeschooled like that's something
that's pretty important what do we think
about child rearing what do we think
about gender roles in the household what
do we think about Breadwinners what do
we think about
um go financial goals what do we think
about that like all of these things are
born out of your values and if you've
got value alignment pretty much
everything else psychological stability
all the rest of the stuff as long as
you've got those things you can usually
work through most of the other stuff but
if you haven't got those and you're just
like we both like playing pickle
ball good luck now it seems like from
that study a lot of it really comes down
to someone's agreeableness or
disagreeableness and I know you talked
about this in another podcast where
people want someone who's malleable in
the Middle where you're not going to
hold these extremely firm beliefs either
way and it's more about the person being
able to see the perspective of another
side mhm so how much of this for men and
women comes down to whether or not
they're disagreeable and they're going
to be difficult in a relationship well
don't forget disagreeability can be sexy
right like disagreeability
is it's like push back that's what
flirting is kind of a little bit about
right like someone doesn't quite fold to
what you want they go no like you like
you do it it's like oh right okay that's
kind of there's something there's
something exciting about that
um in my
experience guys will tend to have an
easier time with women who are agreeable
like if every single thing that you do
is a battle to like um why don't we go
here for dinner I don't want to go there
so okay why don't we go there for dinner
oh I don't want to go there I guess
you're just going to choose every okay
why don't you choose I'm like you want
me to choose that and that is just the
predisposition of certain people right
and that the same can be true reverse as
well if every single thing that you do
with your partner is a battle if every
single thing that you do is a war that's
not fun right conversely if that person
is com so Placid that they always just
fold to whatever your desires are why do
you want to go for dinner tonight oh I
don't care what do you want to do
tomorrow oh you choose like why don't we
do this thing yeah sure like well like
give me something here because if
someone is permanently just agreeing
with what you say it's basically the
same as not being in a relationship with
anybody so again again as with
everything it's like where's this nice
Spectrum that's in the middle now
there's some people that prefer Jeffrey
Miller evolutionary psychologist is uh
married to Diana Flashman Diana is like
one of the most disagreeable people like
she is a self-identified like female
tetrad so like dark Triad uh psychopathy
melanism uh and narcissism although I
don't know how much she's got on the
narcissism but she's like kind of waved
her finger in the air a little bit and
being like yeah like I'm pretty high on
psychopathy like wow like that's that's
what Jeffrey likes Jeffrey likes the
fact he's got this really high IQ quite
disagreeable woman that he like contends
with right he contends with his wife but
that's because of him like he's this
like even like more crazy IQ like super
super smart dude so that's what he's
about but I would say on average
like agreeable especially agreeable
women seem to be like my friends that
are in relationships with them seem to
have like an easier time and it's that
if everything is a battle for all of the
decisions that you have to
make not very much is fun you're always
working pretty hard to try and just get
the smallest thing across the line you
want to have battles about the big stuff
not about all of the stuff that's just
like that's literally just being in a
war and that doesn't sound good why does
it seem like masculinity is shunned
lately I think Modern Men are being made
to pay for the advantages that their
fathers and grandfathers
had and in a world in which we've moved
from a brwn based to a brain-based
economy and you don't need protectors
and providers that much we've allowed
women to access education and employment
and become socioeconomically viable on
their own they don't literally don't
need no man for many of the women two
women for every one man completing a
four-year us college degree women aged
21 to 29 earn 1,111 more than men on
average so they're literally like ahead
by most of the key objective metrics
that people under the age of 30 care
about what's the role for men in that
and it's also there's a current trend of
it being cool to dunk on whoever was
seen to have had the advantages in the
past right it's like straight white male
syndrome like straight that had
advantages in the past because people
who are homosexual were mistreated
[__] Alan churing was chemically
castrated uh White slavery wasn't that
long ago like yes also had some benefits
male women women weren't allowed to go
to university until not not so long ago
they etc etc etc
but it it
uses errors of the past to make
compensations in the present and that
fundamentally means that like men as one
of the biggest groups that have seemed
to have had some kind of benefit
immediately get dunked to the bottom of
the pile and yet if you look even
remotely closely at the outcomes that
lots of guys are getting I don't think
that there's much evidence that guys are
flourishing at the moment like I think
the first quarter of last
year like 33% of new CEOs were
female and that was heralded as like New
Frontier but until it's at 50% it
doesn't matter like God do 50% of women
want to be CEOs like really is that a
life that you aspire to I don't [__]
aspire to be a CEO and I owne my own
company I don't want to be a CEO it
sounds like it sucks I'm looking forward
to the day when someone else steps in
and takes that role
so guys have had it had it good in some
ways for a while and it's just
like it's like cultural reparations for
men to pay this fine
that certain areas of the world believe
that they owe to people and that means
that like mistreating them or
considering them to be in a privileged
position is something that everybody
should focus on how do you navigate that
as a guy not
self-pitying I think like
would it have been easier as a guy to
have been born 50 years ago maybe like
maybe
because you would have been able to out
earn and out educate most of the women
in your local Village or whatever uh
pretty easily because 50 years ago was
when Title 9 was introduced which was to
get more women into universities so it
would have been you would have been the
highest performing person in hypergamy
would have allowed you to have risen to
the top and women more women would have
found you attractive but it's not and
pitying yourself or pitying the world or
like screaming and and creating a victim
mindset around yourself is literally
just giving the power to somebody else
this is Alex's thing right it's like
wherever you point the finger of blame
or wherever you point the finger of
responsibility is where you point the
finger of power it's like if you do that
it's like this is you this is you it's
only you that's going to come and save
you with regards to this so navigating
is difficult I think that being open and
honest as a guy as well like look it's
[__] tough it's tough in in many many
ways
and even if it looks like guys have got
it all sorted from the outside I I think
that there are so many that are
struggling and that's something that
there needs to be a like a big cultural
shift around a massive cultural shift so
you talk about suppressing men right
that's what's the word that you use what
do you mean like how masculinity and men
like you go into war mode and then when
you're not in war mode you're suppressed
or something like that I'm not sure if
that's me well you used a different word
rather thaned how like masculinity or
whatever is diminishing okay or how it's
in a point right now where like it's
kind of being hidden okay I would say
it's being eroded yeah for sure eroded
yeah yeah yeah sure so that is a product
of the environment that we're inh so if
that is the case you can't necessarily
change the environment no government
body is going to step in and change the
environment and that's just going to be
a byproduct of the environment that we
are placed in how do you then
necessarily like change that like are
you supposed to just accept the fact
that it's an issue okay it's an issue
and it's because of external factors
that we can't necessarily change and if
you look at data it shows that like you
said test or you've claimed or whatever
testosterone is like decreasing and
masculine is decreasing and stuff like
this what do you do about yeah
testosterone's dropped .1% every month
since 1950 that's crazy that's the way
that people get uh prescri trt from
doctors so a lot of the time there's a a
bunch of places in Austin that do
this doctors will use the normal range
for testosterone levels for men from
1950 to gauge off whether or not you've
got low testosterone could they have
just been high in 1950 or is it like no
it's just well maybe I don't know I
guess we we we didn't have the the
levels in like 1850 but I would want to
know what happened between 1850 and 1950
for us to be like oh and that menle had
this huge surge in in testosterone that
doesn't seem like it's going to be too
likely but yeah dude I don't disagree
like if any other group has a problem we
ask what can we do to fix Society if men
have a problem we say what is it that
men are doing where they can't fix
themselves like we spend billions and
billions in taxpayer funded money to set
up Charities and initiatives and
research to try and help groups that are
struggling
like the biggest risk to a man under the
age of 30 in terms of his own mortality
are literally the hands that he
has like you're more likely to die by
Suicide than any other way under the age
of 30 or 18 to
30 like that's a big deal it's a [__]
big deal that doesn't sound like
privilege to me oh well you know guys
have had it good for so long yeah well
like [__] apart from the war and the
dangerous jobs and they're like 40% of
us only 40% of us reproducing it's like
60% of men not reproducing like that
doesn't sound very good in terms of how
you can at least begin to change the the
culture around it I think that accepting
that guys are struggling and like
changing the narrative like the dead
beat dad like the hom Simpson the Peter
Griffin the like sort of stupid father
role if you ever watch any kids TV show
as well it's always that the boys are
kind of boisterous and and and clumsy
and and try to sort of cheat or or use
their size or their group numbers in
some way and the girls are smart and
like clever and and more dexterous and
and they end up winning because they're
more like noble and and uh um inventive
in the way that they come up with stuff
it's like all right well what's the
subtext that that tells young boys not
to say that like girls shouldn't win
[__] like they should but I'm not
convinced that like an entire generation
of people that were brought up Homer
Simpson and Peter Griffin have got like
high expectations for themselves again
if you're taking a role models from that
and this is one of the other things that
come across like
look should you really be looking to
Homer Simpson and Peter Griffin for your
like father role model advice probably
not but in a world that's got more
single parent households than ever
before and more absent father figures
than ever before where should they look
all of the people that had problems with
Jordan Peterson's Ascension or Andrew
Tate's Ascension where
should the guys that followed them got
their role models
from genuine question
where should they well they should have
got it from Dad what if Dad wasn't at
home cuz that's a huge percentage of
young
boys they should have got it
from i' I'm yet to hear from the people
that are usually critical about that
stuff like a good answer you have to
hear someone say hm yeah like whatever
[__] initiative this is sports stars
are superheroes or something it's like
all right well like that's what people
see their public figures on the internet
as they see them as as like what thought
leaders in some way or another or a
surrogate father figure you talk about
the tall girl problem can you elaborate
on that I said before women are out
educating and out earning
men the problem is that women are
fundamentally attracted to men who are
more educated and wealthier than they
are this amounts to a ever increasing
group of high performing women competing
for ever decreasing group of ultra high
performing men right if more women women
have education levels of undergraduate
or above or even college level or above
of high school or above and of a uh high
level of earning you have this
decreasing group of guys that are above
and across from them women have this
vestigial hypergamy which is like an
ancestral hangover they want to on
average date men who are at least as
educated and at least as earning as they
are this causes a problem because it
results in this group of men kind of
being invisible to women results in a
large group of women compe for a small
group of guys who don't need to commit
so they can use and discard this group
of women who end up being uh either
chasing guys down for a very long time
or Melancholy and just exiting the
dating World entirely couldn't you say
the same thing with guys just in general
wanting to date someone who's more
attractive than they are do you find
anything like that and wouldn't the same
apply to to women that guys would say I
want the most attractive women they want
the most attractive they want the most
attractive women that they can but on
average men and women end up matching
off in terms of uh like out of 10 rating
they tend to be like five State fives
and eight State eights that seems to be
the way that they match off but we're
not talking about the way that people
look we're talking about something which
is much more malleable than that through
culture like it hasn't been that as
women got socioeconomically more
successful guys managed to get more good
looking or something you know what I
mean yeah you were talking about
motherhood M and you were saying that it
was very underappreciated and I tend to
agree with that it seems as if people
were shunning motherhood or not taking
it as seriously as they should and
thinking why would you want to just be a
mom you could have a career you could do
this and do that think about that
sentence just be a
mom like literally creating the future
of our species isn't a big deal yeah
just be a mom yeah man I mean that's how
powerful the patriarchy is the
patriarchy is so powerful that they've
managed to convince women that they can
both be the bread winner and the mother
and that we just get to stay at home and
and play Xbox all day like that's
[__] that's impressive like that that
that's managed to occur but dude like
come
on Modern women believe that true
freedom is having sex like their brother
and working like their father I'm not
convinced that that's true they're not
culpable to their husband in the way
that they would have been before this is
something that like the manosphere never
talks about and a lot of dating online
never talks about look at how low the uh
divorce rates were 50 years or 100 years
ago look at how uh more effective it was
for people to get married and stuff like
that yeah but how many women stayed in
relationships with men because they were
literally Financial prisoners like no
one really ever talks about that and
it's like women have now been liberated
to make that choice but they've also
been encouraged to believe that
motherhood makes them a second class
citizen I don't think that that's true
like there's very few women that I know
that have said having a kid was like the
worst thing that I ever did or I'm so
glad that I worked more and spent less
time with my child very very particular
woman that says that now maybe you could
say wow that's because like who's going
to say that they hate their kid I don't
know like there's a few people on Tik
Tok that do that was like that girl with
a list did you see that I didn't I've
seen a lot of ones on Reddit though dude
it's [__] weird there's like
literally women taking videos of their
newborn child and saying like I can't
believe that I brought this thing into
the world like I don't like it it like
this girl made an 8 page 350 item it's
called hashtag girl with a list you can
go and look at it on on Tik Tok right
now yeah she made an eight-page list of
all of the different reasons why she
didn't want to have a kid including like
can't wear cute heels anymore won't be
able to go to brunch with the girls
literally a parasite growing inside of
my body and then the list of reasons to
have a kid was like half a page long so
there's just this very like averse
to Motherhood culture at the moment
Chelsea conoboy wrote an article for the
New York Times maternal instinct is a
myth that men
created okay is that the same across the
entire animal kingdom are we like what
what do you mean here like just how
powerful is the patriarchy that we manag
to convince women that they want to have
kids how the [__] do you think we got
here like how do you think that we manag
to survive all this
time very strange it's very strange it
seems like we're coming back to that
though it seems like a I've noticed a
traditional movement that I haven't seen
10 years ago that's coming back to
people saying you know what I don't want
the career I want to be home I want to
have kids I want to raise a family and
it seems like now people are really
standing up to that and saying I think
that's really Noble I think it's that's
it's not easy to do it's very difficult
uh and the sacrifice that that would
take I think is is significant well
Downstream Downstream from anything new
like something that's new and novel
people get excited about oh my God like
women have got access to the workforce
you test it for a good while and again
we don't always do our own sense making
we have to learn by failing and you
Outsource some of that to the rest of
the world that's the abene Paradox in
some regards right so like lots of women
being told this is something and again
the loud the CEO boss [__] like leanin
sort of girls like maybe it is great for
them like maybe that's the perfect life
they could lead and if they were a
mother they'd be [__] miserable
totally fine but you can't use that and
whitewash the entire rest it would be
the same as saying saying every Dad
should be a stay-at-home dad like no
like no very few people would agree that
that's the optimal life setup for every
guy but yet it may be for some but you
don't use like even major cases like
majority cases to smear the entirety of
a group you use like each different
person tries to work out what it is for
themselves but yeah man the um I do
think that the motherhood thing swinging
back around uh but this is still the
Aftershock the after effect of the
introduction of reliable contraception
do you know that after the introduction
of the pill single mother pregnancies
went up not down and why is that because
prior to Reliable
contraception an out of wedlock birth
was seen as the man's mistake and after
reliable contraception it was seen as
the woman's choice so shotgun weddings
went
down
single motherhood went up the number of
abortions went up after the increase
after the introduction of hormonal birth
control like who could have predicted
that I don't think that there's anybody
on the planet that would have been able
to work out like the down before then
the consequence was so big that if
you're going to sleep with somebody
there's a very high likelihood of ending
up pregnant and because of that you're
very careful of who you're with after
that you don't have to have that same
level of care and
accidents happen uh not only the same
level of care but also the same level of
obligation sure like do you know why
it's called a shotgun wedding well
because the dad sits there as like you
better get married to my daughter gets
kicked down yep when's it happening son
yep well and you go hey hey hey hey she
could have taken the pill do you know
that she could have did she decide to
she's decided to keep this like it made
it the woman's obligation and and not
the man's mistake or the woman's choice
and not the man's mistake so yeah dude
we're still playing with an awful lot of
Technology like reproductive technology
what does this mean what does it mean
to split off and bipoc having sex from
making babies and then what does it mean
to do it again and split off having sex
from being in love having sex from being
married having sex from having feelings
there's articles in L and Cosmopolitan
how to sleep with him and not catch
feels like how do I disembody myself
from literally one of the most sacred
things that I can do with another human
like that's what that article could be
Rewritten as and again like dude I come
from a nightlife background like [__]
that's what we literally what people
were going out for for the most part you
would lose entire networks of people
because some key guest Lister had got
into a relationship it's like oh for
[__] sake like Jonathan's back in a
relationship again God damn it like
we're going to lose wait in four months
time he'll be out of it and it'll be
fine and we'll like get his group of 15
friends that would come out every
Thursday back or whatever but yeah I
I think that the trends are moving in
the right direction overall I think that
we've got Reason for Hope and I don't
think that people should be too cynical
about the way that the future's going to
end this off I have a few personal
questions what is your biggest
insecurity that I'm not good enough
period that I'm not good enough that's a
thought at everything at everything okay
the same way as you being driven by the
paranoia
of whether the S&P is going to move like
aggressively tomorrow or whether
someone's going to like break into the
house one of the one of the thoughts
that I have a lot of the time is like
what if I'm not good enough like what if
what if this failure is some sort of
judgment on me as a person what if that
lack of performance what if that lack of
recognition what if that uh lack of
actualization what if that poorly spoken
sentence what if that all of those
things I'm like what if I'm not good
enough I'm working through it what
if well if you actually run it down I
mean it's completely illogical fear like
because the fear is if I'm not good
enough I'll be cast out and no one will
like me and no one will care about me
and I'll be on my own and I'll die like
that's the that's the embodied sense
right that's the like limic feeling but
if you actually step in and fact check
it you go
nothing nothing but overcoming the way
that you feel when that happens and
actually allowing yourself to have that
equinity to be like ah I'll be fine like
there's nothing to worry about but yeah
that I'm not good enough is is a a big
one and when is the last time you cried
oh dude I had I shed a tear yesterday
when I told Alex's story on the
podcast
um therapy week and a half
ago watching clouse the Christmas
movie watching an adaptation
uh A Christmas Carol I cry pretty
regularly I'm pretty emotional person I
would love to hear that story but I'm
afraid we which one the one you cried
when you were telling Alex it wasn't
anything big it was just like me I think
it I think it was something that I
really cared about is like I was
reminiscing about some some like person
that inspired me and uh I cry pretty
regularly I'm still like that's another
degree of like I still haven't got to
that stage of being able to do it on the
show like I just it makes me feel so
like weak and vulnerable and I hate it I
hate that like oh [__] like my emotions
are rising to the surface again because
having emotions to me is at least in
some way seen as being like oh this
makes me weak or vulnerable or or or
less do you think guys should be
forthright about their crying should
they crys I think they should be
forthright about whatever they are
because anything else is just [__]
posturing anything else is just you
performing and is that what you really
want like to look back on life and go I
was never myself but at least no one
ever saw the the failings of me is that
really like [__] heroism to you
because it's not to me and that's one of
the things like if I could change one of
the things if I could give a piece of
advice to me from 10 years ago it would
be fear less because I fear a lot I
feared a lot and that's still one of the
like recurring themes even now [__] 2
million person YouTube channel and and
Peterson and Goggins and Rogan and all
the rest of the stuff still there and
I'm like right okay like how can I
continue to impact this and maybe that
you know we asked at the very beginning
why should people listen to you it's a
really good question that I haven't been
asked before like I guess first off I
didn't ask anyone to listen to me like I
just did it because I wanted to learn
and then people seem to like learning
along with me too but the other reason
maybe why they do listen at least in
some regard is like I'm failing
forward learning out loud practicing in
public like I'm doing all of this in as
open of a way as I can I could still be
way more open I'm not Destiny open but
I'm
like I'm as open as I can be about this
and maybe people like I don't know see a
version like see someone going on a
journey that they can resonate with and
and and maybe that helps I guess one
quick thing that I saw on Twitter that I
wanted to get your opinion on because it
has to do with
therapy uh this is quote unquote a super
hot take it got millions of views and it
says the normalization of therapy is
becoming a bad thing for society I'm
seeing more and more people one use the
fact that they are in therapy as a get
out of jail free card for awful Behavior
two believe everything their therapist
says as gospel truth with no further
research required three equate the act
of going to therapy with the actions of
being a good person I'm not saying
therapy is bad for everyone but I am
seeing a trend of less people less
personal responsibility for bad behavior
and a lot more talk about therapy as the
only solution and it got commented and
replied to by an Elon Musk and this is
what he
said the D Emoji dude I think that's a
great take I don't like I don't think
that's a particularly hot take at all I
think that therapy culture and the the
normalization of therapy languages is
dangerous like people have mistaken
going to therapy for doing the work like
even your therapist will say it's
integration after you have these
conversations right uh for me it's been
very very very Illuminating I've not
been doing tons of therapy throughout my
entire life and I maybe should have done
more it's been very very Illuminating
there's very few places and this is like
I'll fly the flag at least a little
bit there's very few places where you're
allowed to be
boring you're not even really allowed to
be boring around your friends like if
you're having a conversation and your
thoughts are messy one of the things
that you learn in therapy is to pay
attention to fleeting thoughts and to
not believe that you're supposed to have
a cohesive narrative or sentence when
you open your mouth like you're trying
to get stuff which you haven't formed an
opinion about or haven't really
understood you're trying to like get it
into something that's out there and that
results in you making lots of u-turns
and and messing up and and not really
knowing where you're going and maybe
circling the same point for like 20
minutes even the best friend in the
world is going to be like dude this
[__] sucks like I'll sit here but
like it they would say is this a therapy
session there's very few places that
you're allowed to be boring like
emotionally boring and repetitive and
messy and there are very few places in
which you can actually be completely
100% this person would be [__] canned
by their psychology
Psychiatry Board license board if they
said the things that I'm saying to
them like being petty about stuff or
talking about things that are
unbelievably embarrassing like those
things are important and it's not for
everyone it's not a Panacea maybe I'm
going to find out maybe I'll I'll change
my opinion in like 5 years time or one
year's time or six months time I don't
know but at the moment it's interesting
and uh especially if you spend all of
your time talking to other people and
like like being on being in a place
where you don't have to like oh and
Winston Churchill once said like this
[__] thing like is is really really
really important and good so not for
everybody but nether is a knife bath
cool thank you thank you so much for
coming on the ice C really appreciate it
you have to remind people to subscribe
CU they're not subscribed we're on a
race to a million subscribers we got to
beat Caleb Hammer hmer he does the
financial audits on YouTube okay he's
got a cooler name mhm but a worse
channel name I like it okay so subscribe
to the ice coffee hour and uh graem will
sneak into your house late at night all
right check out Chris he'll be linked
Down Below guys also got a shout out
these are really good you sent me some I
absolutely loved it I was wild sold
can't sold out Across America sold out
in some flavors in the UK uh go to new
tonic.com you can sign up modern wisdom
on Apple podcast Spotify Chris
Williamson on YouTube boys I really
appreciate you I love what you're doing
massive fan of your channel massive fan
of the podcast it's been [__] awesome
to catch up we're going to go Po and
then I've got an hour and 40 minutes get
on a flight we got to go
thanks oh yeah yeah
just